en 5 ans alors pourquoi ce soigner coûte
de plus en plus cher est-ce que l'on va
vers un système de médecine à deux
vitesses et comment garantir l'accès aux
soins pour tous on en parle dans
dialogue citoyen l'mission de l'échange
direct entre citoyenne citoyen et
parlementair sur Public
Sénat dialogue citoyen demain à 16h30
sur Public
Sénat
bonjour bonjour à tous très heureuse de
vous retrouver sur Public Sénat pour le
105e congrès de l'Association des maires
de France un programme riche cet
après-midi autour de 15h45 vous allez
pouvoir suivre en direct le discours de
David lissnard le président de
l'Association des maires de France il
sera suivi de l'intervention de la
première ministre Élisabeth born qui
clôturera ce 105e congrès et auparavant
vous allez pouvoir suivre également en
direct l'hommage à Samuel Paty et
Dominique Bernard ces enseignants qui
ont été les victimes du terrorisme en
présence de Michell Paty la sœur de
Samuel paaty et pendant un peu moins
d'une heure nous allons aussi et bien
débattre sur ce plateau je vous présente
mes invités deux experts expertes sur ce
plateau Chloé Morin bonjour vous êtes
politologue votre dernier livre je le
cite on aura tout essayé publié aux
éditions Fayard face à vous Stéphane
Vernet bonjour bonjour rédacteur en chef
délégué directeur de la rédaction de
Paris de West France à côté de vous
Muriel Fabre bonjour vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'Association des
maires de France et maire de l'impè Time
et puis le sénateur renaissance des
hautes scènes Xavier yacovelli va nous
rejoindre d'ici un instant un mot
d'abord Muriel Fabre sur et bien la
thématique euh générale hein de ce 105e
congrès communes attaquées républiqu
menacées tout ça s'inscrit dans un
climat général de violence après
notamment les émeutes de l'été il y a eu
160 écoles qui ont été prises pour cible
des postes de police municipale des
hôtels de ville attaqués ce sont des
événements qui ont marqué tout le monde
tous les Français et en premier lieu les
maires évidemment que ça a marqué mes
mes collègues maires vous le le thème de
notre congrès le le le trouver un petit
peu fort pour autant quand on interroge
autour de nous on pense qu'il se qu'il
s'inscrivent vraiment aujourd'hui dans
dans nos menac et dans nos attaques vous
l'avez rappelé effectivement comment ne
pas mettre en exerg les les cibles que
sont aujourd'hui les symboles
républicains vous l'avez cité les les
bâtiments publics les écoles mais aussi
les élus nous sommes en première ligne
nous sommes attaqués de toutes parts
mais c'est aussi finalement prendre en
compte en fait l'ensemble du contexte
dans lequel aujourd'hui s'inscrit notre
mandature une gestion de crise une
recentralisation financière
des injonctions contradictoires une
inflation normative qui pèse aujourd'hui
et qui effectivement met finalement en
exergue un malaise profond de mes
collègue maire et on va essayer de
développer tout cela tout au long de ce
débat Chloé Morin comment déjà
comprendre pour vous cette flambé de
violence qu'il a eu et bien ces derniers
mois alors si on ritue les choses en
fait il y a eu ça fait longtemps qu'il y
a une défiance extrêmement
marquée vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des
responsables politiques et cette
défiance jusqu'à présent elle se
traduisait assez peu par des actes bien
qu'il y ait de plus en plus d'insultes
et cetera et en fait c'est que récemment
que on s'est rendu compte de l'ampleur
du phénomène à travers un certain nombre
de de symboles et notamment par exemple
la famille de Vincent jeambbrin le maire
de la île et rose qui avait été attaqué
pendant les émeutes je pense qu'on a mis
du temps à se rendre compte du phénomène
simplement parce que les élus
eux-mêmes parfois ont honte de se
plaindre non enfin son longtemps été
tout seul face à à aux insultes qu'il
pouvaent recevoir voir aux actes de
violence donc euh maintenant la la
parole s'est assez libérée finalement
sur ce phénomène mais je pense que
pendant longtemps le fait même d'être
euh je vais pas dire détesté mais d'être
frappé d'une défiance très marquée
faisait que les élus se disaient bon bah
je vais pas me plaindre en plus parce
que déjà que les gens trouve que je suis
incompétent inefficace et cetera et
cetera euh je vais pas en rajouter mis
un peu le le couvercle là-dessus pendant
des mois xavia Covelli vous qui êtes élu
des hautes scènes là où les émeutes ont
ont commencé avec quelques mois de recul
comment comprenez-vous ces attaques dont
les communes dont les les symboles de la
République ont été l'objet alors moi je
je suis pas là pour pour donner des
excuses en tout cas au aux émeutes elles
sont inexcusables et aujourd'hui moi je
salue encore une fois l'attitude des
maires quelle que soit leur sensibilité
et et dans mon département il y a
différen différences de de sensibilité
mais ils ont tous eu le même discours
d'appel au calme et de et de maîtrise et
de maintien de de l'ordre dans leur dans
leur collectivité après il y a des
facteurs différents effectivement qui
ont apporté ces ces émeutes mais encore
une fois je pense que l'accumulation
puisque c'était ça le sujet
l'accumulation des attaques et des
menaces envers les élus en 2023 ont été
importantes et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que le gouvernement a a fait ce plan de
de prévention des violences contre les
élus c'était aussi pour ondre à une
vraie problématique que nous rencontrons
sur le terrain sur le terrain sur les
réseaux sociaux les menaces de mort des
menaces physiques aussi et et mon
collègue jeanbrin de lessonne a a
effectivement subi directement auprès de
auprès de sa famille et dans son
habitation donc on voit bien qu'il y
avait besoin d'avoir des des réponses
fortes et et et moi je vois aussi une
mobilisation y compris de la justice
puisque 85 95 % je crois euh ont des il
y a une réponse pénale pardon pour 95 %
des cas et 84 % euh de Pein de prison
ont été prononcées sur sur ces attaques
donc on voit bien qu'il y a une
mobilisation des pouvoirs publics de la
Justice de la police et c'est et c'est
normal dans ce sens-là parce que encore
une fois il faut protéger ceux qui font
la démocratie au jour le jour
c'est-à-dire les élus locaux euh une
mobilisation face à une société de de
plus en plus violente Stéphane Vernet
est-ce queon peut dire ça aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr que la société de plus en
plus violente le le phénomène monte
depuis depuis des années le et je je
vais reprendre le propos de Chloé Morin
c'est vrai que là on est en train de se
rendre compte de l'impact de cette
montée générale du niveau de violence
dans la société qu'elle soit physique
verbale et cetera enfin ça se traduit
par des choses très concrètes parce
qu'il y a eu quelques cas emblématiques
il y a eu le maire de de de Saint-Brévin
Lespin qui qui a démissionné en Loire
Atlantique on parlait de Laer rose tout
à l'heure il y a il y a eu le cas
dramatique de ce maire qui est qui qui a
été tué alors qu'il était en train de
verbaliser un un le maire de signe en
2019 c'était là que tout avait commencé
on avait vraiment commencé
voilà donc il y a un certain nombre de
phénomènes qui nous font prendre
conscience du problème et c'est pas que
le problème des mè c'est pas un problème
d'élu c'est un problème général de
monter de la violence dans les sociétés
or il se trouve que quand vous avez ce
type de phénomène qui se qui se qui se
qui se développe qui se
débride il y a a on sait qu'il y a en
fait toute personne tout dépositaire de
l'autorité publique se retrouve
particulièrement ciblé c'est-à-dire que
face à une espèce de frustration une
montée de de d'adrénaline de violence il
y a le côté défouloir le besoin de de
s'en prendre à quelqu'un qui incarne
quelque chose or aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe si vous voulez je pense c'est que
dans la répartition des compétences leur
exercice la façon qui fait quoi pour le
citoyen pour l'écrasante majorité des
citoyens tout ça n'a pas de sens c'est
très confus c'est mal identifié et donc
en fait on on prend le responsable qu'on
a sous la main et qu'on va agresser y
compris sur des choses qui n'ont rien à
voir avec ces compétences souvent le mer
c'est le plus proche on dit que c'est
l'élu le plus proche donc ça et pour le
pour encore une fois pour le citoyen ce
qui compte c'est que c'est que les
services ou les les choses dont il a
besoin soit lui soit rendu dans de
bonnes conditions au bon moment mais si
vous voulez en fait tout est mélangé et
mais donc ou il y a du coup vous vous
retrouvez avec des des Maes qui se font
insulter prendre un parti menacer
agresser de plus en plus y compris sur
des choses qui ne relèvent pas de leur
compéten mais vous avez aussi une
flambée des violenceces et les
agressions à l'égard de tous les
fonctionnaires tous les agents que soi
fonctionnaires d'État fonctionnaires
territoriaux les agents hospitaliers on
a une montée en fait de cette de cette
problématique avec des chiffres qui qui
qui s'affolent qui relèvent de la même
logique et pour lesquelles à un moment
il va falloir trouver des réponses
adaptées parce que parce que ça pour pas
continuer comme ça répon oui Muriel fa
c'est quoi la réponse aujourd'hui sur ce
continuum de violence finalement dont
vous parlez vis-à-vis de toute personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique et
puis bon si on élargit au climat actuel
peut-être même bien plus largement hein
mais il y a plusieurs réponses à
apporter bien évidemment il y a déjà et
et avant tout en fait un accompagnement
et un soutien à à nos collègues maires
par rapport à cela c'est pour ça que
nous en fait on s'en était saisi au sein
de l'association des MRES de France
extrêmement rapidement avec la mise en
place d'un observatoire avec un
conventionnement avec France victime et
aussi des des séquences de formations
avec le raid et GGN parce que ça nous
semblait important aussi d'être dans la
prévention mais ce qui compte
aujourd'hui finalement aussi c'est à mon
sens deux éléments déjà une question de
transparence une transparence sur les
causes effectivement on on sait qu'elles
sont multifactorielles mais si on ne les
analyse pas de manière précise et
concrète on ne pourra pas y trouver des
solutions pertinentes et adaptées donc
on a besoin effectivement d'un travail
très fort alors je pense notamment à
kalaé qui a été mis en place par par le
gouvernement pour avoir vraiment des
études statistiques précises en la
matière parce que je pense que c'est
important une transparence aussi bien
évidemment sur le déploiement des
effectifs et des moyens parce que la
question des moyens euh au niveau des
mairres on on n'arrête pas d'en parler
mais c'est aussi la question des moyens
au niveau de la justice et au niveau de
la gendarmerie au niveau de la police
nationale pour faire des enquêtes pour
poursuivre et pour effectivement arrêter
en fait finalement toujours ces
classements sans suite par manque par
manque de personnel notamment au niveau
du parquet je pense que c'est
extrêmement important d'avoir ça en tête
et ce qu'on sollicite aussi c'est une
effectivité des peines aujourd'hui le
sentiment d'impunité des auteurs auteurs
d'infraction de violence vis-à-vis des
élus moi j' j'en rencontre beaucoup des
collègues maires sur les départements
c'est d'ailleurs on était ensemble avec
Chloé Morin sur sur une association
départementale où on avait ce sujet-là
sous v ils nous disent mais soit c'est
classé sans suite soit je n'ai pas de
retour effectivement sur sur mon dépôt
de plainte et on a besoin aujourd'hui de
renforcer cette effectivité avec aussi
effectivement la prise en compte de
cette caractéristique finalement
complémentaire supplémentaire que si
nous sommes aujourd'hui victime de
violence c'est parce que nous sommes
effectivement symbole d'une autorité en
proximité je pense que c'est extrêmement
important et on a entendu effectivement
des témoignages tout au long de ce
congrès des maires notamment ce
témoignage fort et écouteter ce maire du
pas decalais qui s'est fait l'écho de
cette violence qui s'exprime à son égard
en tant que maire en tant qu'élu local
écoutz j'ai été insulté mes employés
aussi au début de l'année mais avec
menace de brûler la mairie j'ai déposé
plainte la personne est passée très
rapidement au tribunal elle a été
condamnée à 4 mois et surc elle a quitté
le département
elle défectuera jamais sa peine elle est
partie ailleurs elle recommencera et
puis en partant elle m'a fait un beau
bras d'honneur en disant je
t'emmerde on peut espérer son
qu il monte je suis éluis 1989 j'ai fait
un mandat de conseiller municipal un
mandat d'adjoint c'est mon 4e mandat de
MRE ça n'a jamais été aussi difficile ça
n'a jamais été aussi difficile quelques
chiffres la montée de la violence envers
les élus statistiquement serait à plus
32 % en 2022 cela devrait être encore
plus 15 % sur 2023 selon les prévisions
2023 n'est pas encore terminé Chloé
Morin qu'est-ce que vous inspire ce
témoignage que l'on vient d'entendre et
qui illustre bien ce cette cette montée
en puissance de la violence ces
dernières années sur la question de la
la justice malheureusement ça s'inscrit
dans un contexte plus global de
d'immenses difficultés de la justice à
euh justement faire son travail pour des
raisons notamment de moyens pas
uniquement sans doute mais notamment de
moyens c'est pour ça que euh quand la
réponse du gouvernement a été d'abord
d'alourdir les peines oui c'est c'est
sûr que on peut alourdir les peines et
alourdir les peines mais s'il y a pas
les moyens pour condamner les gens pour
faire les enquêtes c'est ce qui ce qui a
été dit à l'instant euh on n'ira pas
très loin et il y a le risque aussi dans
l'opinion que les Français se disent ben
on on donne les moyens pour les élus
dont on pense que c'est plutôt des
privilégiés et cetera enfin il y a quand
même énormément de clichés vis-à-vis des
élus et on donne pas les moyens pour
protéger les les citoyens français c'est
c'est la difficulté de de cette
problématique là et donc il faut aborder
la question à mon sens de la justice
dans son sens large et puis derrière
cette cette violence il y a évidemment
des facteurs multiples mais il y en a
peut-être deux qui sont qui sont
intéressantes à à relever un facteur qui
est global qui est quand même la manière
de s'adresser à l'ensemble des services
publics et la manière de se comporter
des citoyens qui en fait de plus en plus
se comportent comme des consommateurs de
service public et donc qui considèrent
que les élus sont là pour leur rendre
enfin que que les les son à leur service
et que finalement parce qu'ils payent
des impôts tout leur est dû et ils n'ont
finalement que des droits et pas de
devoirs je pense que ça ça évidemment ça
n'engendre pas toujours un passage à à
la violence mais ça explique un certain
nombre de comp comportement qu'on ne se
serait pas autorisé auparavant et puis
il y a un deuxième élément je pense
c'est l'incompréhension de ce qu'est le
rôle d'élu moi je suis frappé de ce que
les citoyens ne savent pas finalement
quel est le quotidien d'un maire ou d'un
élu que ce soit sénateur députés et
cetera il n'en voit finalement qu'un une
toute petite partie qu'on voit
éventuellement quand les les députés
s'engueulent dans l'hémicycle et donc ça
donne une image des élus qui est
complètement délirante alors que en ité
les élus et les maires en particulier
sont sont pris dans un faisceau de
contrainte qui est extrêmement fort et
et et finalement doivent prendre des
décisions
quotidiennement qui sont pas qui sont
pas faciles Xav Covelli vous qui sortez
en plus de la campagne des sénatoriales
vous leur avez prêté une oreille
attentive à tous ces élus locaux ils
vous l'ont rapporté ça le fait qu'ils
l'impression et bien qu'aujourd'hui
leurs administrés les consomment comme
disait Chloé Morin oui oui c'est c'est
exactement ça ça c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui les Français on le voit dans
nos dans nos communes et quelle que soit
d'ailleurs la sociologie de la commune
c'est avant tout des des consommateurs
plutôt que des acteurs et et d'ailleurs
c'est assez particulier c'est-à-dire que
on voit que nos concitoyens demandent de
plus en plus de participer à l'action de
la coconstruction vous savez c'est le
grand le mot à la mode de cononstruire
les politiques publiques et lorsque les
élus jouent le jeu et font la
cononstruction font des budgets
participatif des conseils de quartiers
ouverts en fait on se rend compte qu'il
y a à peine 10 % de la population qui
qui participe alors vous dites quoi il
faut il faut pas le faire ou il faut
faire en sorte que franis sent Mobilis
par CEJ on a on a souvent les Français
sont souvent maintenant des
consommateurs du service public sans se
rendre compte qu'en fait on on on on
œuvre dans un collectif et que 85 % des
élus locaux ne sont pas indemnisés dans
notre pays que c'est un sacerdoce et
c'est souvent pour travailler pour
l'intérêt général avant tout et que
aujourd'hui on a besoin effectivement de
valoriser c'est pour ça que nous on
prône le statut de l'élu local
la MF le pronos mais on attend ce statut
d'élu local il y a eu un certain nombre
d'avancé depuis 2019 sur sur le sujet
mais il faut effectivement pouvoir
travailler sur comment est-ce qu'on
accompagne les élus à exercer leur
mandat qui est un mandat le mandat d'élu
local c'est du lundi au dimanche c'est
pas vrai il y a pas on ne ferme pas la
porte de de son bureau et on rentre
tranquillement chez nous on est
aujourd'hui complètement corps et âme à
à à notre mandat local et donc il faut
pouvoir valoriser ça il faut pouvoir
avoir c'est c'est passerell aussi dans
le monde de l'entreprise il faut aussi
avoir favoriser l'implication des femmes
et donc avec tous les mordes de garde
qu'on peut aussi avoir et comment est-ce
que la vie de famille aujourd'hui peut
être conciliée avec un mandat local que
ça soit un homme ou une femme d'ailleurs
et donc il faut pouvoir avoir ce ce TR
sur il faut un texte il faut aussi une
une volonté il faut mettre des moyens
mais là où je suis pas complètement
d'accord avec avec vous c'est que par
exemple sur la question de la justice on
a effectivement alourdi les peines sur
les les les attaques contre contre les
élus mais on a aussi mis 40 %
d'augmentation du budget de la justice
qui n'était jamais arrivé on a mis les
moyens mais on a on arrive de tellement
loin qu'effectivement on a besoin
suffisant voyz on se rappelle par
exemple du maire de Saint-Brévin qui
avait eu l'impression personne ne
l'écout dans n'importe quelle société
quand on augmente 40 % 40 % le budget
d'une société personne n'accepterait ça
aujourd'hui on a augmenté de 40 % le
budget de la justice depuis 2017 ce
n'est pas encore assez il y a encore
beaucoup de progrès à faire mais on est
sur la bonne voie et on essaie de
rattraper surtout des années d'inaction
sur sur la justice vous voulez réagir cl
oui non je suis d'accord qu'on part de
loin juste un chiffre qui est d'ailleurs
un chiffre de l'AMF 80 % des maires ont
une indemnité nettement inférieure au
SMIC horair je trouve que ça illustre
tout à fait ce qui vient d'être dit euh
quelques autres chiffres issus de
l'enquête du svof sur les violences he
dont les maires sont victimes 69 % des
maires déclarent avoir déjà été victime
d'incivilité plus 16 points par rapport
à 2020 39 % disent avoir subi in jure et
insulte plus 10 points 27 % disent avoir
été attaqué sur les réseaux sociaux plus
7 points Stéphane Vernet et bien les
chiffres ils sont on l'a dit ils sont
extrêmement éloquant
oui oui ils sont en augmentation ils
sont très forts enfin je enfin
rendez-vous compte 39 % de de maires qui
disent avoir été insultés ou menacés ça
veut dire que quat MRES sur 10 se font
insulter et menacer donc voilà il y a
évidemment c'est le problème est énorme
je juste j'aimerais juste rebondir sur
ce qui vient d'être dit je trouve je
trouve je trouve très intéressant le le
le il y a plein de choses qui sont mises
en place ou aujourd'hui le plan de
protection des élus la loi évolue il y a
la proposition
de par leat au mois le fait de renforcer
les peines qui sont prévu pour les
agressions donc on peut pas dire que
rien n'est fait il y a plein de choses
qui est fait qui sont faites pardon et
qui vont à mon avis dans le bon sens
mais ce que je trouve très signif
significatif c'est ce que vous avez dit
sur les budgets participatifs je pense
que c'est vraiment le problème il est là
c'estàdire que il y a une espèce de de
d'injonction contradictoire il y a une
demande très forte de participation on
veut pouvoir participer et effectivement
les communes qui le font constatent que
il y a 10 % parfois moins de de citoyens
qui font et en plus c'est toujours les
mêmes non mais voilà donc alors il y a
une espèce de demande et donc ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'en fait il y a
pas de formule magique elle est là aussi
la difficulté c'est que c'est pas vrai
de dire que rien est fait plein de
choses se font euh il y a des
initiatives qui sont prises on essaie de
répondre à la demande euh et en réalité
ça fonctionne pas pourquoi parce que
parce que derrière il y a il y a il y a
un véritable problème de comportement et
encore une fois ce sont des phénomènes
de société qui sont extrêmement complexe
et très profond vous avez Dominique fort
la ministre en charge des
collectivitoriales qui dit il faudrait
un choc de citoyenneté je pense que sur
le fond elle a raison le problème c'est
que ça se ça ça se décrète pas un choc
de de de citoy par quoi voilà voilà
c'està-dire que c'est une question c'est
une question de responsabilité partagée
mais ça doit venir de de ça doit venir
de tout le monde en fait le problème il
est là c'est c'est et et et tant queon
aura des citoyens qui se comportent
d'abord comme des consommateurs parce
que c'est exactement ça mais on arrivera
on ne résoudra rien vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est dire que on peut prendre
toutes les mesures qu'on veut mais tant
que sur tant qu'on aura pas fait notre
révolution culturelle et collective je
pense qu'on ne résoudra aucun des
problèmes qu'on a devant nous et le
problème c'est que personne n'a de
formule magique pour résoudre ce
problème qui est un problème essentiel
et de fond Muriel Fabre on est tous
collectivement responsable du coup aussi
bien sûr qu'on est tous responsable et
et et de sur croi bien évidemment aussi
les les les élus locaux en fait le le
constat qui est fait c'est que on est en
plein cœur d'une crise d'une crise
civique telle qu'on ne l'avait jamais vu
en fait ça ça se constate évidemment par
les T les taux d'abstention ça se
constate effectivement par une des
citoyens aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
consommateurs des citoyens qui
deviennent de plus en plus violents qui
souhaite finalement une immédiateté de
réponse alors qu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui
nos délais sont de plus en plus longs
bien évidemment et c'est finalement
uniquement le fruit de notre impuissance
publique c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui d'être
dans l'incapacité d'agir dont notamment
les démocraties locales que sont les
collectivités et je pense qu'il faut
réaffirmer aujourd'hui le socle de notre
démocratie que sont aussi les communes
de leur redonner les moyens d'agir pour
pouvoir aussi répondre aux besoins de
nos concitoyens qui se font de plus en
plus pressant et croissant et je pense
que c'est extrêmement important parce
que pour redonner en fait finalement du
lien citoyen ça passe d'abord par de
l'efficacité Xavier Covelli vous voulez
réagir oui juste je pense que le choc de
citoyenneté la seule réponse c'est pas
seulement pas seulement ça c'est aussi
le choc de simplification en fait de
notre action publique et aussi de
redonner on ne pourra pas redonner de
l'autorité au maire si eux-mêmes n'ont
pas les compétences qui vont avec
l'autorité et et c'est un peu le
problème moi encore une fois quand quand
je recevais des citoyens il y a 15 ans
dans ma
permanence on était en capacité de
répondre à à sur la question du logement
sur la question des permis de construire
sur la question des places en crèche sur
la question même des des papiers
d'identité aujourd'hui on va voir un
maire on va voir un élu local bah en
fait la place en crèche bah non
maintenant c'est délégué donc ce c'est n
plus laabéie on va voir pour un logement
ben non en fait là c'est le Cotat d'Allo
donc c'est la préfecture on va voir pour
un permis de construire ah bah non les
permis de construire c'est
l'intercommunalité donc en fait on a
petit à petit enlever des prérogatives
au ma et qui sont pourtant le premier
contact avec le citoyen et sont
aujourd'hui dans l'incapacité de pouvoir
apporter une réponse concrète et ils
sont obligés de dire bah non c'est
l'échelon supérieur et donc la
multiplication des des échelons
intermédiaires et supérieurs sur nos
décisions publiques font que en fait on
a enlevé de l'autorité au maire et et
donc si on a plus d'autorité et ben il y
a plus de respect sur sur les élus
locaux et je pense que c'est avant tout
la simplification de de notre de notre
et plus de décentralisation et de
pouvoir pour pour les maires un choc de
simplification plus de décentral ation
c'est ce qu' a premier Emmanuel Macron
hier effectivement devant les élus
rassembl à l'éisée alors on a dit à
plusieurs reprises autour de cette table
qu'en fait le les citoyens qui se
comportent comme des consommateurs ne
comprennent plus et qui fait quoi
comment ça marche et cetera c'est
complètement vrai je souscris totalement
à ce que vous venez de dire c'est au
cœur du problème mais c'est pas la faute
des citoyens qui seraiit irresponsable
ou indifférent et cetera c'est aussi
qu'on y comprend plus rien parce que
tout est complètement mélangé il y a un
problème de de simplification de
clarification des compétences c'est ce
qu'a promis le le président de la
République hier soir à l'Élysée quand il
s'adressait au au maire là-dessus
c'était quand même sur ce pointl il
était particulièrement intéressant il a
dit on va désembrouiller tout ça et
c'est je pense que c'est ça fait partie
des nécessités absolues et parmi c'est
parmi les premières choses à faire
effectivement qui fait quoi qui est
responsable de quoi qui a les moyens
pour exercer quelle compétence on est
arrivé à un dans un système où ça fait
des années ça fait des années qu'on se
dit collectivement qu'il faut changer
tout ça ça ça fait des années qu'on que
qu'il y a des promesses qui sont faites
des initiatives qui sont prises et ça ne
marche toujours pas et là là c'est
peut-être la première des choses à faire
pour pour améliorer les choses il a le
bon diagnostic Emmanuel Macron il a le
bon diagnostic mais depuis plusieurs
mois déjà parce que me semble-t-il que
le chantier de la décentralisation ça
fait quelques mois qu'on en parle et que
le président en parle donc aujourd'hui
effectivement on attend alors évidemment
vous dit les résultats la mission mais
on attend des actes bien évidemment
l'association des mèes de France elle pr
une décentralisation depuis depuis
longtemps avec des éléments très
concrets en la matière effectivement
avec une simplification bien évidemment
bureaucratique avec une clarification
des compétences entre l'État et entre
les différents échelons et celles de la
commune effectivement ne l'oublions pas
la question financière bien évidemment
un mot sur l'absence d'Emmanuel Macron
qui n'est pas venu au Congrès des maires
qui a donc reçu à l'Élysée 1000
maires qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
est-ce que vous auriez souhaité qu'il
vienne dans le contexte qu'on vient de
décrire là de depuis plus de 20 minutes
où les maires effectivement attendent
beaucoup de soutien aujourd'hui moi je
ne je ne souhaite rien du président de
la République hormis aujourd'hui qu'on
puisse nous redonner la capacité d'agir
je pense qu'il appartient au président
de la République d'avoir lui ses
éléments d'explication pour savoir s'il
doit venir ou pas au niveau du Congrès
des Maires vous le savez on attend
énormément de
réponses certainement et en tout cas on
l'espère que la première ministre tout à
l'heure nous proposera quelques avancées
j'espère qu'elle ne vient pas sans rien
dans dans dans sa mallette mais après
effectivement le choix du président lui
appartient un mot Chloé Morin sur
effectivement les les relations parfois
difficiles entre Emmanuel Macron et les
élus locaux et dont l'absence
aujourd'hui enfin cette semaine a été
très commenté hein il n'est pas venu à
Porte de Versailles ouis les c'est vrai
que les relations avec les avec les avec
les maires ont été comment dire il y a
eu des haut et débat pendant pendant ses
deux mandats euh il a su en tout cas cas
les trouver et et travailler main dans
la main avec eux quand la France a a
traversé des moments difficiles et
particulièrement pendant le covid ou
même avant pendant les la crise des
gilets jaunes donc on voit bien qu'il y
a une une une importance donné au maire
mais c'est vrai qu'après on rentre très
vite dans des comment dire on parlait de
la simplification par exemple c'est un
c'est un serpent de mer François
Hollande avait promis un choc de
simplification et le truc avait été é
enterré d'une manière complètement
incroyable par l'administration enfin
par la haute administration en
particulier en dépit du fait qu'il y
avait un ministre qui poussait qui pour
pour le choc de simplification qu' avait
un plan qui était quand même assez
réfléchi et cetera et cetera et donc
c'est c'est on a l'impression que ce
combat là est un combat immense et tout
ça pour dire qu'il y a manifestement des
sujets sur
lesquels le président de la République
et les maires seruront retrouvé des
intérêts commun et pourront se battre
ensemble et je pense que c'est la les mè
ils attendent surtout les actes comme
vous le dites he le diagnostique il est
connu depuis sans doute même de de
longues années chacun chacun est dans
son rôle et donc et donc
nécessairement il y a des demandes qui
sont faites et c'est au président de la
République de de trancher mais moi j'ai
le sentiment que j'ai c'est quand même
qu'il y a beaucoup sur ce sujet-là de de
il y a un diagnostic qui est quand même
assez largement partagé du côté des
maires comme du côté du gouvernement et
donc c'est là que ça peut donner quand
même l'espoir que des choses xavell oui
il il y a un diagnostic partagé mais
effectivement les solutions ne sont pas
toutes partagées et en fait quand on
parle de
simplification il va falloir mettre
d'accord ceux qui représentent les
régions ceux qui représentent les
départements ceux qui représentent les
intercommunalités ceux qui représentent
la métropole en l'occurrence de du Grand
Paris et ceux qui représentent les
communes et en fait le problème c'est
que quand on parle de simplification
quand quand quand on veut faire de la
simplification et enlever des strates on
on a toujours un une association d'élus
qui dit bah non moi je veux pas qu'on su
ma strat donc c'est ça aussi le problème
c'est qu'il faut qu'on soit en
responsabilité aussi tous autant que
nous sommes en se disant par exemple je
prends l'exemple de l'île-de-francece on
a CIN strates C strates on ne sait même
plus en tant qu'élu en tant qu'élu
locaux on ne sait même plus qui s'occupe
de quoi donc on a aujourd'hui besoin
effectivement d'une simplification c'est
la mission la feuille de route que le
Président de la République a confié à
Eric WZ pour pour justement cet acte
suppément de la décentralisation mais je
pense que la décentralisation elle ne
peut pas avoir lie si on n' pas aussi le
financement qui va avec on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui décentraliser un certain
nombre de compétences sans avoir les
financements qui vont qui vont avec et
aussi recréer et moi je je sais que
c'est pas très populaire mais je pense
qu'il faut recréer ce lien entre le
citoyen le contribuable et l'élu local
et donc la commune il faut que la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation moi
j'étais je suis très favorable à la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation mais
c'est vrai que ça a coupé le lien entre
le citoyen et la commune et donc il faut
réfléchir à quelque chose quand le
président de la République annonce d'une
refonte complète de la DGF qui
effectivementation glale de fctionnement
la dotation globale de fonctionnement
qui est en augmentation ou en stagnation
sur un certain nombre de communes depuis
qu'Emmanuel Macron est présence qui
était inédit sur les précédents
gouvernements mais on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui elle est encore injuste
et c'est insuffisant et qu'on a
aujourd'hui besoin de recréer du lien
local avec avec le financement et la
décentralisation Stéphan Verner est-ce
qu'on peut croire à un Emmanuel Macron
décentralisateur alors qu'il a été vu
comme un président recentralisateur par
de nombreux élus locaux et vous venez
d'évoquer la taxe d'habitation on peut
parler aussi et bien de la de la CVAE
hein voilà tous ces impôts que les élus
locaux ont donc perdu alors moi je crois
qu'il est qu'il est sincère qu'il le
veut vraiment j'ai pas de doute
là-dessus le problème c'est que ça fait
des années maintenant qu'il qu'il
l'annonce qu'il le promet qu'il ne se
passe rien il a été très bon hier soir
j'ai trouvé dans son dans son discours
les quatre points qu'il a à l'Élysée
pardon ou les quatre points qu'il a
qu'il a qu'il a qu'il a évoqué c'était
c'était concret c'était simple je
voudrais et et je je pense que ce ça
c'est c'est terrible mais je pense que
ça restera le discours le plus
intéressant de tout le Congrès sauf
qu'il il s'est pas tenu au Congrès on
verra euh j'exagère mais on verra non
juste un juste un point je trouve
intéressant sur le la la la la la toute
la question de la simplification des
compétences et euh la clarification des
compétences et de la simplification le
président en a parlé hier euh vous
évoquez le la suppression de strat c'est
il est pas question de suppression de
strat Eric vert l'a dit ici hier matin
et dans sa lre de mission lui il part
pas dans l'idée de supprimer des strates
il a il a rassuré tout le monde le
président de la République l'a redit
hier soir à l'Élysée il est pas question
de supprimer des strates par par contre
toute la problématique de la
simplification elle vient pas forcément
des collectivités elle vient d'abord des
administrations et de la passion
française pour l'empilement des normes
le président a pris un très bon
exempleerre ilit regardz le protocole
sanitaire à l'issue du covid pour les
écoles au début quand le gouvernement
l'a pondu ça faisait deux pages à
l'arrivée le document faisait
80 prenez l'exemple de la loi
immigration quand le projet de loi
arrive au Sénat sorti de donc de du
gouvernement il fait 27 articles oui on
est à presque 100 voilà 92 ou 93 on a
multiplié par 3 la taille du texte c'est
insensé et c'est comme ça tout le temps
et pour tout sans arrêt et c'est pas une
question de de mairie de de de
département de région c'est pas une
question d'élus locaux et cetera
on a compif ch ah non mais d' d'une
manière complètement délirante et après
vous retrouvez tout en bas donc le maire
qui se retrouve avec des directives des
normes et vous avez plein d'agences et
de structures qui pondent des normes en
permanence qui s'empilent qui sont
contradictoires les une par rapport aux
autres à l'arrivée pour les appliquer
c'est juste pas possible c'est l'enfer
plus personne n comprend rien et là vous
incapacitez de manière très
spectaculaire ce fameux pouvoir d'agir
donc peut-être qu'on pourrait commencer
par ça et ça se passe pas forcément au
niveau des élus mais vraiment là aussi
on a besoin d'une révolution d'un choc
culturel et euh et et à tous les étages
mais il faudrait le faire assez vite
parce que ça fait des années qu'on se
traîne ces boulets et à force de d'avoir
aucun changement et aucune amélioration
il y a un moment ça va ça va finir par
craquer mrial Fab effectivement le
résultat c'est que ça commence à craquer
lorsqu'on voit et bien le nombre de
démissions des maires et des élus locaux
la crise des vocations 40 maères qui
démissionnent chaque mois le constat il
est terrible c'est le résultat sans
doute de ce climat de violence dont on a
parlé au début de ce débat et aussi et
bien de cette incapacité à agir he par
tout l'environnement que que l'on vient
de décrire évidemment c'est c'est tout
cela c'est des conditions d'exercice du
mandat qui sont effectivement de plus en
plus difficile une conciliation vie
professionnelle et exercice du mandat
c'est un contexte financier qui devient
de plus en plus tendu parce que oui on a
une augmentation de la dotation globale
de fonctionnement mais en Euroc constant
donc qui ne correspond comp part à
l'inflation et on sollicite une
indexation just 7 milliards en moin en
tenant compte de l'inflation absolument
avec des dépenses de fonctionnement bien
évidemment qui augmentent résultante de
de l'inflation de la Haus des coût
énergétique puisque on le sait en fait
les dépenses d'une collectivité ne sont
pas les mêmes donc notre l'impact de
l'inflation n n'est pas le même donc une
réduction aussi d'investissement donc
nous ne jouons plus notre rôle de moteur
économique donc nous ne pouvons pas
mettre en place finalement tout tous les
projets que nous souhaitions en
démarrage de mandature on est
aujourd'hui à mi-mandat avec le constat
qu'effectivement d'un sentiment
d'inutilité et ça ce n'est plus possible
et et c'est vrai que je comprends ces
mères qui qui qui qui finalement jettent
jetteent l'éponge parce qu'à un moment
donné quand vous êtes dans l'incapacité
de faire alors que votre rôle est d'agir
ça devient une équation contradictoire
Chloé Morin équation contradictoire nous
dit Muriel Fabre oui oui moi j'ai la
crise d'évocation c'est quelque chose
pareil qui qui qui vient de loin et qui
qui et de qui prend une ampleur
démesurée de la même manière qu'on a des
déserts médicaux un jour on aura des
déserts électoraux c'est-à-dire que ça
devient tellement difficile
voilà et ça devient tellement difficile
il y a tellement pas de euh de de
comment dire de considération et de
rétribution même symbolique vis-à-vis de
de l'engagement que finalement on se
demande pourquoi est-ce que les gens euh
iraientent se présenter euh devant pour
pour représenter leur leur concitoyen
donc ça c'est pareil c'est c'est pour ça
que tout à l'heure je parlais de de de
facteur de multi de crise
multifactorielle parce qu'en réalité il
y a pas que la violence il y a la le la
bureaucratie l'enfer administratif dont
on a parlé il y a le sentiment
d'inutilité il y a la capacité à
concilier vie professionnelle avec un
mandat et vie personnelle avec un mandat
aussi il y a toutes ces choses-là et
c'est pour ça que la réflexion sur un
statut de l'élu est sans doute est sans
doute indispensable c'est que il faut
prendre vraiment le
problème dans dans sa globalité si on
veut éviter une crise d'évocation majeur
Xavier yacovelli Emmanuel Macron il a
été élu en
2017 on le dit ces sujets il ne datent
pas d'hier est-ce que vous regrettez
qu'on n pas plus pris à bras le corps
tout tous ces sujets au niveau du du
gouvernement quand on voit aujourd'hui
la situation et bien voilà des
démissions de la crise d'évocation et
cetera le le regretter c'est c'est une
évidence on aimerait toujours faire
toujours plus vite et tout de suite vous
l'avez dit il y a aussi la lourdeur
administrative le le poids aussi des des
différents blocages qu'on a pu recevoir
et puis accessoirement on a eu quand
même quelques crises pendant le premier
quinena et et et le début du du second
et donc effectivement il a fallu aussi
s'adapter et adapter la réponse à
l'urgence et aux différentes crises le
président de la République a un discours
qui aussi a changé et et quand même
assez assez clair sur sur les clés de
redonner du pouvoir de redonner
pleinement du pouvoir d'agir au maire et
ça passe par effectivement trois clés on
l'a dit la décentralisation un acte
supplémentaire de décentralisation une
rénovation plus juste de la dotation
générale de fonctionnement la DGF et
puis plus de simplicité pour
effectivement éviter d'avoir une un
accumulation de une accumulation pardon
de de de normes tout ça ce sont les
effectivement les clés pour donner plus
de pouvoir aux maires ça c'est un
engagement du Président de la République
je pense que effectivement son discours
c'est peut-être celui qui restera le
plus important en tout cas pour pour les
les élus locaux lors de de ce congrès et
je pense que c'était vraiment une
attente des élus maintenant il faut
mettre en œuvre et et c'est à nous
maintenant on va dire pouvoir législatif
de pouvoir mettre ça dans la loi vous
déplorez son absence au Congrès des
maire vous avez entendu le débat
politique he qui qui est né autour du
fait qu'Emmanuel Macron ne soit pas venu
ici directement voires élus rassembl
enfin sincèrement est-ce que c'est à la
hauteur qu'il soit là ou pas là hier il
a fait des annonces dans le cadre du
congrès des mairres où il recevait plus
de 1000 maires il les recevait à
l'Élysée son rôle c'est de faire en
sorte que les chos avanceent qu'il donne
le cap il a donné le cap hier dans le
cadre du congrès des mares je suis pas
sûr que s'il était venu aujourd'hui au
Congrès des maires à Porte de Versailles
saurait changé quelque chose à son
discours pourqu pourquoi n'est-il pas
venu c'est parce que c'est c'est c'est
compliqué encore aujourd'hui pour lui de
se retrouver je je ne suis pas sûr que
ça soit compliqué et je pense que
maintenant on connaît bien Emmanuel
Macron pour savoir qu'il
ne il ne refuse jamais aucun obstacle et
qui n'a pas peur de contact et
certainement pas des élus locaux et donc
oui je pense que c'est c'est un choix et
en tout cas ça s'est fait comme ça et
honnêtement c'est il a pas été présent
sur tous les congrès des mares et tous
les présidents n'ont pas été présents à
chaque congrès de M il y a il est venu
je crois une ou deux fois depuis son
élection voilà il a fait des annonces et
c'est ça le plus important inf faau
procès Stéphane Vernet mais oui c'est
pas la première fois qu'il vient pas au
Congrès des Maires il me semble que la
dernière il y a une fois il était venu
au salon et pas au Congrès ça lui avait
déjà été c'était le cas l'année dernière
effectivement où il avait déambulé dans
dans le salon des maires qui est dans le
bâtiment d'à côté honnêtement c'est pas
un sujet franchement enfin c'est je
comprends que ce soit un sujet de
politique politicienne mais c'est pas le
c'est pas le c'est pas le fond du c'est
pas le fond du problème et encore une
fois je pense que ce qu'il a ce qu'il a
dit hier était était intéressant
notamment le le sur le la question du
statut de l'élu qu'on est qu'on évoquait
en disant premet temps qu'il y a il y
aura un texte un un pour un vrai statut
de l'élu l'année prochaine ça c'est faut
voir ce qui sortira du du chapeau mais
je je trouve que dans le là où il était
intéressant aussi c'est qu'il a beaucoup
insister sur le le couple maire préfet
en disant que ça c'est quelque chose qui
avait marché qui marche à chaque gestion
de crise pendant la pandémie voilà qui
marche à chaque gestion de crise et il
dit voilà il faut que dans un couple
maire préfet qui fonctionne il faut
qu'on vous donne le pouvoir à vous les
maires de déroger donc il a parlé de
déconcentration et de le le le le fait
de pouvoir déroger et de d'avoir d'avoir
une possibilité de de de différenciation
ou d'expérimentation je trouve que ça
c'est très intéressant le problème c'est
qu'encore une fois ça fait partie des
choses qui sont annoncées ou promises
depuis des mois voire des années et ce
qui est difficile là où ça va commencer
à être vraiment problématique c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est toujours pas
en phase opérationnel parce que au bout
d'un moment ça va finir par se voir
enfin ça se voit déjà mais ça va finir
par devenir un vrai problème vous nous
promettez ça à chaque fois il se passe
rien il serait il serait plus que temps
d'arriver à des choses concrète et qui
correspondent aux demandes des élus et
que ce soit pas que les Mair les élus
locaux en général Murel Fabre oui
simplement pour pour rebondir sur les
les les propos le président de la
République hier s'est exprimé
effectivement devant devant 600 700
maire il était évident qu'il allait être
dans ce que nous attendions je pense
qu'on ne pouvait pas ça ne pouvait pas
être autrement en fait la
décentralisation c'est quelque chose que
nous sollicitons la simplification c'est
quelque chose que nous sollicitons la
question financière et la réforme de la
DGF c'est quelque chose que nous
sollicitons donc oui évidemment c'est
ces trois items nous parlent mais comme
je l'ai déjà dit aujourd'hui on en parle
il faut et je vous rejoins maintenant
c'est désormais des actes derrière une
mise en
mais évidemment enfin je veux dire à un
moment donné il faut quand même qu'on
soit dans une dans dans une je dirais
similitude moi je voudrais revenir sur
sur cette histoire de combat il y a pas
de combat entre le gouvernement et
l'association des mes de France on
travaille pour la même chose on
travaille pour la République et on
travaille pour la démocratie ce que nous
souhaitons nous c'est effectivement un
État fort et des collectivités à côté
fortes donc la question de la
décentralisation et d'ailleurs le
président l'a rappelé hier s'accompagne
d'une déconcentration aussi qui doit
être efficace avec notamment la
simplification la question des agences
les injonctions contradiuctoires entre
entre services déconcentrés ça on n'en
veut plus aujourd'hui mais la question
de la dérogation on nuance un petit peu
à l'association des mères de France
parce que oui différenciation mais pas
dérogation systématique parce qu'à un
moment donné déroger c'est pas décidé
non plus donc il faut aussi être
vigilant à ce
niveau-là un mot sur et bien un hommage
que vous avez tenu à à faire aujourd'hui
en cette séance de de clôture de
l'Association des mères de France Noel
Fabre vous avez choisi tout d'abord de
rendre hommage à Samuel paatti à
Dominique Bernard ces deux enseignants
qui ont été les victimes du du
terrorisme pour quoi et en quoi cet
hommage est aussi lié à ce dont on parle
aujourd'hui est lié au ma mais vous
savez les enseignants on l'a dit les
écoles aujourd'hui sont des cibles
également parce qu'ils sont
représentants filement dans un dans un
certain sens de la de la République donc
il nous semblait important de pouvoir
aussi rappeler dans le cadre de notre
thème République menacé et de les mettre
de les mettre en lumière aussi dans ce
cadreel je pense que c'était important
de pouvoir rappelez que nous sommes
aussi au côté de l'ensemble des agents
publics qui aujourd'hui subissent des
violences des agents publics qui sont
victimes d'agression et d'attentat
terroristes on ne peut pas nier cette
cette question aussi en France
aujourd'hui et et l'association des
mères de France dans dans une union
républicaine se devait de de participer
et de mettre en lumière nos deux
enseignants xavia Covelli un mot sur cet
hommage à Samuel paatti à Dominique
Bernard sont des symboles de de la
République menac
attaqué et qui fait bloc aujourd'hui
aussi face à ces attaques oui je pense
que pour le coup il y ail y a unanimité
au sein de de la MF auprès du
gouvernement des parlementaires sur le
fait de défendre nos valeurs et et une
de nos principales valeurs c'est la
laïcité et c'est aussi la la liberté de
penser de de s'exprimer et surtout
d'instruire et donc je trouve que le le
signal envoyé par la MF est un bon
signal et moi je m'y associe
complètement et et je pense que c'est
important parce qu'en fait Samuel pay
comme Dominique Bernard son sont
effectivement sont en première ligne
parce qu'ils étaient en première ligne
parce que c'était des enseignants mais
c'est au même niveau que les élus locaux
qui sont en première ligne face au à des
peut-être à des délinquants ou à des
personnes violentes et qui pourraient
effectivement s'attaquer à eux et on l'a
vu un certain nombre de mères ont été
également violenté ou même il y en a un
qui était qui a été tué donc euh je je
pense qu'il faut pouvoir faire bloc que
la République fasse bloc et c'est bien
que quel que soit les sensibilités
politiques on puisse être tous unanimes
sur cette questionl Chloé Morin
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire oui
effectivement ce sont autant de symboles
de de la République attaquer ces ces
enseignants et c'est aussi bien allié
aujourd'hui aux difficultés que que
vivent les maires oui il y a des il y a
manifestement des des des personnes dans
notre pays qui représent des cibles
toutes désignées parce qu'ell
représentent effectivement la publ la
défense de nos valeurs les démocraties
et donc forcément et qu'elles sont en
première ligne et donc forcément d'un
côté les élus de l'autre côté les
professeurs à différents à différents
titres et donc c'est normal que ça soit
comment dire que tout le monde se sert
les coudes et que les uns et les autres
rappellent les valeurs parce que moi ce
qui me ce qui me frappe c'est quand même
l'extrême confusion et une confusion
grandissante euh sur ce que sont ces
valeursl c'est-à-dire la définition de
la liberté d'expression par exemple
et tout le débat sur est-ce que la
liberté d'expression c'est de pouvoir
tout dire où est-ce qu'elle doit
s'arrêter est-ce que on peut dire des
paroles qui peuvent offenser telle ou
telle communauté ou pas tout ce débat là
on se rend compte surtout quand on
regarde la jeunesse qui a énormément de
confusion et on l'avait déjà vu au
moment d'ailleurs des caricatures de
mahomé et cetera donc c'est quelque
chose qui traverse la société et
évidemment que dans ce cadre là dans ces
débatsl qui peuvent être extrêmement dur
et et et violent les maires d'un côté
les professeurs de l'autre sont un peu
en première ligne de quoi sont-ils le
symbole Dominique Bernard Samuel pati
des je disais des symboles sans doute de
la République attaqué c'est aussi des
symboles de de la liberté de de
l'enseignement de de la parole qui doit
être pouvoir être critique il y a aussi
tout cela derrière tout un modèle de de
de l'enseignement qui qui a été bien sûr
mise à mal avec ces deux terribles
assassinats
moi je pense que en fait ce sont surtout
ce sont deux prof les professeurs d'une
manière générale est-ce que ce que les
islamistes visent à travers ses
attentats c'est
l'émancipation et je pense que c'est ça
la cible c'estàdire que libérer les
esprits mais exactement c'est
l'émancipation de la jeunesse c'est la
formation des citoyens le le leur
permettre d'avoir une une une pensée
libre raisonnée construite et donc
l'émancipation et donc le le le le c'est
ce qui fait que les islamistes les
cibles
aujourd'hui l'idée c'est de c'est
d'empêcher cette cette émancipation et
donc oui c'est c'est notre modèle de
société c'est la c'est la République qui
est attaquée mais juste juste un juste
un un un point en complément on parle de
de de de Dominique Bernard de Samuel
paatti mais sur une année glissante vous
avez quatre quatre agents de la fonction
publique qui ont été assassinés quand
même dans l'exercice de leur fonction
hein vous avez vous avez un contrôleur
du un inspecteur du fisque qui qui a été
assassiné il y a quasiment un an jour
pour jour à peu près euh alors qu'il
contrôlait un brocanteur je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez vous avez une
infirmière qui a été assassinée
l'hôpital de reins vous avez Anel
slassal qui a été qui a été assassiné au
professeur à Saint-Jean de luuse et
Dominique Bernard donc donc encore une
fois il y a voilà il y a les maires mais
il y a aussi les agents j'insiste il y a
aussi les les agents de la fonction
publique et il y a une montée des
violences contre tous les agents de la
fonction publique contre tous les
fonctionnaires d'État territoriaux ou de
de santé qui est en train de de de de
monter et ça c'est euh voilà qui qui qui
qui accompagne cette montée générale de
la violence dans notre société et toutes
les personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique deviennent aujourd'hui les
cibles privilégié de ces violence c'est
un message de solidarité que vous leur
adressez Muriel Fabre euh par par cet
hommage aujourd'hui bien évidemment euh
adresser notre soutien et notre
solidarité en tant en tant qu'élu locaux
en tant qu'élu de la République parce
qu'aujourd'hui
on est on est bien conscient que que
nous vivons dans une société où
effectivement ce risque attentat existe
et que les les cibles républicaines sont
aujourd'hui des enseignants çaela peut
être presque n'importe qui je dirais
dans dans dans notre société qui
représente finalement ce symbole
républicain aujourd'hui et il est
important de dire qu'on est là à leur
côté et surtout qu'on ne cèdera pas à la
peur et qu'on ne cèdera pas à la
terreur xavia Covell on est aussi dans
un moment de un contexte où on voit et
bien aujourd'hui une une crise à
l'international il va d'ailleurs y avoir
tout à l'heure aussi une séquence he
consacrée à l'Arménie et donc c'est une
façon aussi pour les maires de de France
de de dire et bien à quel point cette
situation les les préoccupe et est aussi
aujourd'hui l'affaire de tous l'une des
grandes craintes sans doute aujourd'hui
et bien c'est c'est l'importation de de
de cette crise à l'internationale au
sein au sein de la France et qu'elle et
et qu'elle et qu'elle arrive partout en
France oui c'est c'est malheureusement
le cas et on le voit dans un certain
nombre de communes où il y a des
dégradation des des biens publics ou des
biens privés avec des tags avec des
inscriptions qui qui laissent à penser
d'un côté comme de l'autre qu'on puisse
prendre parti sur un conflit qui ne
touche pas directement la France donc où
la France effectivement notamment et
bien la multiplication des ACT an
mulation des actes antisémites on a vu
aussi des actes antimusulmans euh dans
une autre commune donc on voit bien
qu'il y a aujourd'hui une une montée de
la violence de prise à parti on va dire
de d'un certain nombre de bien pour par
rapport à à à à ce conflit je pense
qu'il faut effectivement faire attention
et encore une fois les les les élus sont
en première ligne parce que leur
expression publique et moi je le vois en
tant que parlementaire dès qu'on a une
expression sur sur ce conflit on est
forcément pris à parti d'un côté comme
de l'autre et donc c'est très compliqué
parce que on doit à la fois avoir une
position équilibrée et en même temps
c'est aussi notre rôle de dénoncer un
certain nombre de massacres qui qui ont
pu avoir lieu et donc je pense que c'est
la situation est très compliquée en ce
moment elle est très anxiogène et on
voit bien que n'importe quelle
discussion avec même entre amis entre
familles on a cette situation
internationale qui qui est preignante et
donc il faut faire attention qu'elle ne
s'importe pas mais y compris dans la
violence et dans la montée de la
violence en France oui la situation
internationale aujourd'hui Chloé Morin
elle est aussi à l'origine d'une partie
de cette fracturation accrue encore dans
notre société
oui et puis il y a comment dire il y a
un certain je disais tout à l'heure
qu'il y avait une confusion sur sur les
valeurs c'est une confusion qui est qui
est clairement entretenu par une partie
des responsables politiques aujourd'hui
qui euh peuvent laisser croire par
exemple par leur propos que lorsqu'on
condamne l'antisémitisme et donc
lorsqu'on soutient les Juifs on enlève
quelque chose aux musulmans comme si on
pouvait pas être dans le combat contre
l'antisémitisme et dans le combat en
même temps contre les actes
antimusulmans par exemple il y a des
responsables politiques aussi qui vous
expliquent que lorsque vous combattez
l'antisémitisme en fait vous soutenez
les massacres à Gaza donc il y a une
extrême confusion dans le débat public
qui est qui qui qui n'est pas que dans
la population qui est entretenue parfois
euh de manière totalement je pense
électoraliste par une partie des
responsables politiques et c'est c'est
ça qui qui rend la situation encore plus
compliquée parce qu'en fait je pense que
quand on est un maire devant sa
population on est quelqu part toujours
tenu comptable de toutes les
déclarations des autres politiques et
donc on prend pour les autres vous
parlez de de déclaration il y a un mot
et bien que Emmanuel Macron a regretté
d'avoir utilisé il en a fait état hier
devant les maires réunis à l'Élysée
écoutez la sécurité
la sécurité la sécurité ne jamais
s'habituer et face aux violences qui se
réinstallent à ce que j'ai pu qualifier
de
décivilisations réaffirmer ce sans quoi
la liberté n'a pas de sens qui est
l'ordre
républicain oui nous sommes à à un
moment
effectivement de où on entend beaucoup
beaucoup de mots des cvilisations
ensuvagement a dit également Gérald
dararmanin on entend aussi donc une
grande parole politique hein qui bien
tente de de de de conceptualiser cette
situation qui va parfois dans dans des
excès non oui la polémique ou le regret
c'est peut-être parce que en fait ce
sont des termes qui ont pu être utilisés
à certains moments par des penseurs
d'extrême droite ou et donc qui seraient
connoté après la le le le le au-delà des
termes je pense que il y a y a c'est
c'est les phénomènes qu'il faut regarder
alors on peut on peut les appeler comme
on veut hein peut-être que le mot est
mal choisi n'empêche que le phénomène
lui il existe bien et qu' y a un vrai
problème et donc donc peut-être qu'il
faudrait commencer par bien nommer les
choses certes mais mais je je moi je CIS
je crois que le problème il est pas là
le problème c'est le phénomène lui-même
et c'est comment comment on l'aborde et
comment on le traite euh Muriel Fabre
sur le la responsabilité aussi de la
parole politique dans dans ce moment il
y a eu tout tout un débat je pense
notamment après bien sûr le le drame de
de Crépol c'est ces derniers jours avec
ce jeune Thomas 16 ans qui a été tué
lors d'une d'une Rix qui a eu lieu lors
d'un d'une fête de village il y a eu des
des paroles politiques pour certains qui
qui ont parlé de francooside à l'extrême
droite il y a Éric Coti lui qui a parler
de rakaille et hier j'entendais certains
élus qui disaient on doit quand même
faire très très attention aujourd'hui à
la façon dont on s'exprime à ne pas
enflammer plus un débat qui est
extrêmement inflammable bien sûr
absolument la la la parole publique est
extrêmement importante puisque c'est
finalement gage de de sincérité gage de
conviction gage de de d'autorité aussi
et on est tous et toutes quand on est
élu de la République en tant qu'élu
local ou parlementaire ou autre
responsable de ce qu'on dit et
effectivement je pense qu'il ne faut pas
tiser le feu je je je rejoins que ce
soit un contexte international
géopolitique ou un contexte national il
faut être extrêmement vigilant ne pas
trahir ses convictions bien évidemment
mais je pense qu'il ne faut pas attiser
les les flammes bien évidemment je pense
que là jeen suis clairement convaincu un
dernier mot là-dessus sur on l'a entendu
notamment hier Élisabeth borne au Sénat
qui appelait à la retenue qui appelait à
la dessence aujourd'hui dans dans ce
contexte de de violence avec ces faits
divers qui sont chargés très fortement
en émotion oui mais vous savez l'extrême
droite qu'elle soit de Marine Le Pen ou
d'éc Zemour de toute façon ils font leur
chougrade depuis des années sur sur
cette hystérisation sur cette montée de
la violence et sur des propos
effectivement qui pourraient laisser à
penser qu'il y avait un ensuvagement
effectivement de la société la réalité
c'est que l'enquête doit se poursuivre
moi les premiers éléments que j'ai vu
dans la presse c'était celui qui a
apporté le coup mortel était bien
français et donc c'est pas un
francooscide comme comme Eric Zemour a
pu a pu le faire alors que ce soit des
racailles certainement que ce soit des
délinquences c'est une évidence mais
peut-être qu'il faut quand on est
responsable quand on aspire en tout cas
à avoir des responsabilités politique je
pense qu'il faut effectivement mesurer
les paroles et utiliser la langue
française est assez riche pour utiliser
un certain nombre de de mots qui qui
correspondent un peu mieux que que ce
que l'extrême droite a pu utiliser et
bien merci merci beaucoup à tous les
trois d'avoir débattu alors que nous
sommes en pleine séance de clôture du CE
105e congrès de l'Association des maires
de France on va tout de suite prendre la
direction de la séance plinière où c'est
territoireuni qui est en train de
s'exprimer he c'est-à-dire et bien
és
assoé locend tout de suite la dire
deette ceux qui sont intervenus dans les
différents débats qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons le sentiment que les communes sont
étouffé étouffé par l'administration
étouffé par les finances écoutez y y
a-t-il un moyen plus redoutable de nous
mettre en tutelle que de nationaliser
les impôts et de décider que c'est
l'État qui a la place selon son bon
vouloir parce que on le rappelle
l'annualité budgétaire a un sens peut
décider que nous allons faire plus et
malheureusement trop souvent faire moins
donc il y a la nécessité de cette
autonomie que vous avez tous réclamé à
la fois l'autonomie financière c'est un
principe constitutionnel mais qui a été
disons-le bafoué
bafoué par la loi qui a suivi la réforme
constitutionnelle et qui malheureusement
fait que moins nous avons de liberté
plus nous sommes censés être librees
avouez qu'il y a là plus qu'un paradoxe
il y a un contresens mais en ce qui
concerne la fiscalité aujourd'hui nous
le savons tous quen reste-t-il c'est une
fiscalité en charpie plus rien pour les
régions depuis déjà bon allez 3 4 %
autour des cartes 5 allez 5 soyons
généreux 5 % de marge de manœuvre sur
les départements ils sont quasiment
maintenant arrivés au même niveau que
les régions et quant à ce qui nous
concerne c'est vrai qu'on en a encore un
peu ça a d'ailleurs diminué quand même
de moitié ces dernières années et puis
surtout c'est sur un seul contribuable
le
propriétaire et ça veut dire que nous
n'avons en réalité aucune capacité de
subtilité dans la gestion de réponse aux
Accous parce que nous sommes maintenant
uniquement sur une imposition qui va
très vite trouver son plafond son terme
c'est d'ailleurs le cas dans beaucoup de
nos territoires beaucoup de nos villes
et qui fait que en réalité cet impôt
nous n'avons plus la capacité à le lever
parce qu'il est déjà à des sommets qui
parfois sont difficile à dépasser donc
nous avons besoin de liberté il n'y a
pas de liberté sans moyen et la le
combat que nous menons au sein de la MF
comme il est mené au sein des
départements et régions de France c'est
bien entendu de retrouver les moyens de
la liberté parce que la France a besoin
de commune libre c'est ce qui fait les
pays forts merci André
Lenel des communes libres régions et
départements des libertés locales merci
à Carole Delga et François sauvadé
d'avoir été avec nous en ce début de
cette séance de de de clôture de du 105e
congrès des des maires j'invite
maintenant à nous rejoindre sur
scène Muriel Fabre la secrétaire
générale de l'AMF Antoine Homé afica
resgi et guijoffroid et nous allons
passer dans un instant à un nouveau
temps de cette séance de de Cl
5 105e congrès et ça sera une séance
pleine d'émotion puisque ça un hommage
qui va être rendu dans un instant à
Samuel Patti et Dominique Bernard quand
on dit République menacée et bien ce
temps effectivement est vécu par
[Musique]
tous
David lissnard vous avez souhaité pour
la clôture de ce 105e congrès que nous
rendions hommage et bien à Samuel Patti
à Dominique Bernard qui ont été victime
du du du fanatisme vous avez souhaité
qu'il y ait ce ce moment fort au moment
où se clot le 105e congrès oui c'est une
volonté de l'Association des mères de
France de tous ses adhérents de son
bureau de son comité directeur que de
dire que quand les enseignants sont
attaqués on n'est pas sur du concept ou
du symbole quand les enseignants sont
assassinés quand des enseignants sont
entravés dans leur exercice quotidien de
transmission du savoir des connaissances
de ce trésor qui est la raison critique
la République est plus que menacée
la République est en danger la
République elle est attaquée la
République française nous évoquions tout
à l'heure l'universalisme
l'universalisme républicain est un
trésor de la République française et
qu'à ce titre nous ne pouvons pas rester
inerte nous ne baissons ni les yeux ni
les bras je le répéterai tout à l'heure
et au-delà de l'hommage à deux
formidables enseignants disparus c'est
un message de combativité républicaine
c'est un message de soutien tout
simplement à ceux dont le rôle est
primordial pour constituer les citoyens
de demain nous déplorons nous constatons
nous affrontons les montées de violence
c'est un civisme qui se caractérise par
une perte du sens de la responsabilité
donc de la liberté dans l'espace public
pour rétablir les choses pour proposer
un avenir à nos enfants qui soi un
avenir sûr il faut un réarmement moral
et ce réarmement moral il passe par une
instruction de qualité et par des
enseignants libres d'enseigner les
lumières l'histoire ce qui fait la
France il passe bien sûr par un armement
régalien et par des moyens judiciaires
policiers face au terroristes islamistes
face à cet obscurantisme cet islamistme
dihadiste qui veut tuer et qui veut nous
asservir tout simplement et qui est une
internationale qui malheureusement
s'exprime sur qu coin du globe donc face
à cela et bien la France la République
française ne doit être ni exaltée ni
molle elle doit être clinique ferme
déterminée à faire perdurer nos valeurs
nos principes notre sécurité notre
liberté et donc nous soutenons nos
enseign maillon fort de la République
française merci David
lnard Samuel
[Musique]
Patti Dominique Bernard et d'abord cet
hommage qui commence par des images qui
qui nous rappellent le drame
vécu émotion nationale toute la journée
partout en France despancartes je suis
prof sur la poitrine des marseillaises
des minutes de silence mobilisation pour
rendre hommage à Samuel Patti le
professeur assassin Conflant
sainthonorine 3 ans après Samuel paatti
la France a une nouvelle fois enterré
l'un de ses professeurs victime du
terrorisme islamiste les obsèques de
Dominique Bernard ont été célébrés ce
matin en la cathédrale
[Musique]
d'aras c'était un professeur passionné
qui qui donnait envie à ses élèves de
travailler et on a juste envie de
continuer et pour lui rendre hommage il
était très très gentil et et il était un
peu il avait beaucoup dehumour et il
rigolait avec moi et il me Tainé
[Musique]
aussi nous avons simplement rappelé les
valeurs qui sont les ntres la tâche qui
incombe à chacun de continuer le combat
le continuer le combat qui pour nous
consiste à grandir à faire grandir les
élèves et pour les élèves à grandir à
s'élever dans leur humanité dans leur
conscience du monde qui les entoure
j'aiétis élevé à l'école de la
République avec les leçons de morale la
laïcité et cetera et c'est vrai que ce
sont des valeurs qui sont très
profondément ancrées en moi que
j'enseignais quand j'étais quand j'étais
professeur et qui maintenant sont mis à
bas par le
[Musique]
terrorisme nous devons nous souvenir de
Samuel paatti et de son combat pour
l'éducation et la promotion de la
liberté
d'expression nous avons repris le cours
de nos vies sans pour autant oublier ni
pardonner
ensemble recherchons l'unité
ensemble confirmons notre attachement à
une laïcité ouverte et
[Musique]
généreuse
et nous accueillons maintenant michaell
paatti la sœur de Samuel Patti qui a un
message à délivrer au maire de
[Applaudissements]
France Michel pti rejoignez le le
pupitre nous vous
écoutons
[Applaudissements]
mer je remercie Monsieur David lissenard
président des maires de France et maire
de Cann de me donner l'occasion de
prendre la parole devant vous vous qui
formez le réseau de proximité de la
République laïque et son
tissu le 12 juin dernier l'association
unité laïque présidée par Monsieur
Jean-Pierre scoun a lancé une initiative
nationale à laquelle j'apporte tout mon
soutien celle-ci sollicite tous les
maires ainsi que tous les présidents
d'exécutifs territoriaux pour donner le
nom de Samuel Patti à une voix de leur
commune ou un établissement de
préférence à destination de notre
jeunesse
française des dizaines de municipalités
nous ont fait l'honneur de nous suivre
dans ce combat des plus grandes comme
Toulouse ou Cannes ou plus petite comme
fronton dans le département de la Haute
Garonne toutes les communes de France
s'honoraient en manifestant ainsi leur
attachement à la laïcité républicaine
leur rejet du fanatisme leur espoir dans
la force de l'école de la République
ces idé qui constituent le socle de
notre pays et pour lesquels Samuel pti
et désormais Dominique Bernard ont perdu
la vie il est temps de nous tenir à côté
de tous ces professeurs à qui nous avons
trop longtemps déléguer le risque de
défendre seul nos valeurs républicaines
si je parle de risque c'est que nous
avons àaire à un ennemi et qu'il serait
bien naïf de le traiter en adversaire
qui combattrait à armes égal
défendre et honorer notre République ce
n'est pas un combat d'arrièregarde
l'enjeu est devant nous et notre devoir
de faire preuve d'unité de fraternité et
de courage pour nous opposer aux
offensives islamiques de terreur la
terreur est l'arme de ceux qui n'ont pas
les mots pour défendre une idée mais les
mots ne doivent ni ne peuvent défendre
l'indéfendable il faut également se
rappeler que l'idée de tolérance n'a pas
été conçue pour tolérer
l'intolérable les procédés d'inversion
totale des valeurs sont une vraie menace
pour notre démocratie et pour notre
humanité créer des lieux mémoriels Incit
à se souvenir et à sacraliser la victime
afin de donner un support mat matériel à
l'inilation d'un acte barbare mais cela
ne suffit pas la commémoration ne se
subit pas au combat idéologique pour
repousser et détruire ce qui menace nos
valeurs et principes notre devoir est de
rétablir effectivement l'ordre des
choses afin de pouvoir mettre fin à ce
qui n'est plus que désordre donner le
nom de mon frère à un lieu rétablit son
statut de victime supprime le 8 mai et
finit par nommer l'ennemi pour garder
sans cesse à l'esprit que si nous
baissons notre garde c'est lui qui
reviendra l'ordre des choses nous dit
qu'un acte terroriste n'est jamais un
acte désespéré de résistance face à une
agression supposée ou réelle comment
peut-on soutenir qu'une attaque
terroriste qui torture et tue est un cri
pour la paix un acte terroriste qu'il
soit mené au nom de vieil rancœur ou
d'un esprit
ne peut être cautionné sinon il offre un
permis de tuer aux agresseurs ceux qui
condamn à demiot renvoyant dos à dos
agresseur et agressé finissent par
justifier dans un pseudo équilibre une
attaque terroriste et par réhabilité le
8 mai ce niveau d'évitement et de
[Applaudissements]
contorion de contorsions sémantique
relève du militantisme un militantiste
qui ne cherche nullement la paix civile
mais plutôt à attiser les braises pour
mener une guerre civile le devoir de
mémoire vise à ce que l'œuvre
d'effacement du temps qui passe ne soit
pas inéductable porter les enseignements
du passé permet de se préparer à la
répétition tragique de ce passé c'est ce
qui n'a pas été fait pour mon frère et
c'est donc ce qui a manqué pour sauver
Monsieur Dominique Bernard victime d'une
attaque terroriste islamiste le vendredi
13 octobre
dernier l'assassin d'as a enregistré un
message audio pour signer et signifier
son allégance à daesh permettez-moi de
vous lire un extrait oh français peuple
de l'âcheté et de mécréant j'étais dans
vos écoles des années et des années j'ai
vécu des années et des années parmi vous
gratuitement vous m'avez appris ce
que'est la démocratie et les droits de
l'homme et vous m'avez poussé vers
l'enfer pendant 3 ans nombreux sur ceux
qui se sont évertués à légitimer
l'assassinat de mon frère à grand
enenfort d'omission d'approximation
d'inexactitude et d'insinuation
malveillante afin surtout de ne pas
nommer le mal agissant ce qui se voit
sur de nombreuses plaques commémoratives
qui évit de désigner l'ennemi le
terrorisme
islamique après 3 années d'inaction
l'attaque terroriste islamiste contre
Monsieur Dominique Bernard montre
clairement le visage de l'islamisme
l'islamisme a ciblé à travers ses deux
professeurs l'école républicaine
française chargé d'instruire de former à
l'esprit critique et de faire partager
nos valeurs et principes républicains
tels que la laïcité et l'égalité entre
femmes et hommes autant de principes et
d'ambitions auxquel l'islamisme mondial
voue une haine
absolue ce qu'il faut comprendre des
propos tenus par le terroriste d'aras
c'est que nous ce que nous nous
reconnaissons comme des valeurs ou
principe fédérateur est vécu comme une
offense impardonnable par l'Islam
régoriste ce qui prouve également que ce
n'est pas par méconnaissance de nos
principes qu'il y a rejet mais bien
parce que ceci entre en conflit avec des
personnes qui n'ont que leurs croyances
pour déterminant uni et qui met leur
créateur au-dessus de toute justice et
de toute fraternité s'ils cherchent à
anéantir nos valeurs c'est bien parce
qu'elle les dérangeent eux qui craignent
d'être en péril par
elle c'est pour cela que le seul
enseignement des valeurs et principes
républicains n'est pas un gage de succès
face à des individus endoctrinés qui qui
rejette voir combattent tout ce qu'une
démocratie laïque propose notamment la
[Applaudissements]
liberté cela conforte mes propos tenus
en mai dernier dans la revue humanisme
où je mettais l'accent sur les limites
de l'efficacité du devoir de mémoire les
hommages nous préservent de
l'accoutumance qui mènne à une forme de
collaborationisme et et conforte notre
aspiration à l'humanisme par peur de
devenir inhumain à notre tour la
violence de la résurgence de
l'antisémitisme le 8 mai qui accompagne
si souvent les commentaires sur la
violence islamiste démontre que le
devoir de mémoire est certes nécessaire
mais en aucun cas suffisant pour nous
immuniser contre l'aveuglement et les
dangers qui nous menacent le devoir de
mémoire donne le sentiment de faire ce
qui doit être fait tout en produisant en
effet perverse dévastateur l'émergence
de la victimisation
on a toujours voulu opposer les lumières
à l'obscurantisme il me semble bien naïf
de penser que l'inhumain surgit par
carence d'humanisme en réalité
l'inhumain par définition rejetteent
l'humanisme il me semble également nié
de croire que si on fait preuve de plus
de bienveillance en se soumettant aux
exigences de l'inhumain il renoncera à
ses projets macabres la bienveillance
est ainsi utilisée comme régulateur de
l'humeur de la bienpensance offrant à
ses tenants un anxiolétique naturel qui
s'appelle le déni et finit par
anesthésier toute capacité de voir le
mal mais également le bien l'inhumain
surgit par endoctrinement sacrifiant la
raison à la foi ou à la soumission
l'inhumain surgit dans les processus de
pensées unique propre au totalitarisme
l'inhumain surgit par carence d'esprit
critique face à une propagande Anna
harant a décrit mieux que quiconque le
surgissement de
l'inhumain la mort de l'empathie humaine
est l'un des premiers signes et le plus
révélateur d'une culture sur le point de
sombrer dans la
barbarie inumain surgit grâce à une
alliance improbable de wokistes de
pacifistes de collaborateurs de
prédicateurs et d'oubliés qui apporte
crédit et soutien à la réalisation
d'actes
[Applaudissements]
odieux il y a tout d'abord les
pacifistes qui nous sommes de tolérer de
comprendre et de pardonner un acte
inhumain parce qu'il accomplit par un
homme souffrant il faudra a comprendre
qu'un acte terroriste est commis par des
individus avides de paix et que la
violence est une forme d'expression
comme une autre les pacifistes étant
dans l'émotion et l'immédiateté oublie
vite que si nous cessons de nous
défendre nous cesserons également
d'exister il y a ensuite les
collaborateurs qui par intérêt électoral
et politique ont fait le choix de
soutenir systématiquement les agresseurs
avec l'argumentaire servi à toutes les
Sauses du 8 mai inversant ammanclblement
la relation victime
bourreau ils ont la fâcheuse tendance
d'infantiliser le débat et de brouiller
le rapport de force en se mettant dans
une posture de défense de l'agresseur
qui n'en serait plus un lui-même ayant
été agressé en premier le fameux c'est
lui qui a commencé qui entre les cours
de récréation de nos écoles maternelles
n'oublions pas les prédicateurs
islamistes qui Attis la haine
irrationnelle en invoquant la peur le
dégoût le ressentiment et l'amour de
leurs coreligionnaire quatre sentiments
contre une démocratie il manipulent et
endoctrine toujours tours les plus
jeunes en les retirant toute forme
d'empathie envers un non mususulman et
il les maintienent dans un sentiment de
danger pour tout leur faire percevoir
comme une menace jusqu'à les rendre
coupable de vivre et donc capable de
tuer jusqu'à en mourir au nom de la
culture du
martire l'instrumentalisation de notre
jeunesse se base sur trois principes
tout d'abord la facilité de manipulation
d'un esprit en cours de formation
l'excuse de la jeunesse comme alibié à
tout crime et la clémence de la justice
envers des mineurs qui a qui à qui on
offrira toujours une seconde chance ce
qui procure un sentiment
d'impunité et il y a enfin les
oublier ils sont parfois pacifistes
collaborationnistes ou prédicateurs à
leurs heures perdues parfois même sans
s'en rendre compte mais le plus grand
nombre est le plus souvent en retrait et
attentiste certains oubliés se rassurent
toujours en minimisant la menace ne
regardant que la partie émergée de
l'iceberg celle qui surgit soudainement
après chaque attentat commis par un
soi-disant loup solitaire ce loup qui
n'a de solitaire que le nom ces jeunes
loups sont élevés à mettre leur propre
vie en jeu pour eux on ne se sacrifie
jamais on est sacrifié tous les loups ne
passeront pas à l'acte mais qui peut
prédire celui qu'il le fera il faut
également réaliser que le loup est
galvanisé par la partie immergée qui
tend de plus en plus à
émerger certains oubliés sont les
premiers à féliciter ceux qui prennent
leur part dans le combat contre
l'islamisme et justifie leur propre
paralysie par un je ne sais pas comment
tu fais moi je ne peux pas sous un
sentiment de culpabilité non dissimulé
après un fameux je passe mon tour ils
finissent par un pense à toi alors que
l'agissant pense à
eux ainsi aussi d'autres oubliés se
sentent souvent victimes par procuration
ceux qui leur fournit l'excuse
nécessaire pour ne pas passer pour des
déserteurs ou des mécréants aux yeux de
certains qui scrutent leurs agissements
et qui les obligent à n'être queeux
alors qu'on peut être aussi et en même
temps il faut bien reconnaître qu'en
période de tension et se crée des
alliances dépourvu de raison on peut
voir des pacifiste utopiste de la
réconciliation soutenir des terroristes
en invoquant le devoir d'oubli mettant
l'agresseur et l'agressé sur un pied
d'égalité on peut également voir des
personnes issues de la communauté lgbtqa
plus défendre le programme du Hamas
envers le peuple israélien au nom de la
libération de la Palestine alors que le
Hamas prône la charia donc l'exécution
ou l'emprisonnement de toute personn
issu de la monité LGBT QIA plus et il y
a nos oubliés qui préfèrent réclamer la
paix en prenant l'absurde décision de
choisir un camp il s'accommode également
facilement des débordements ravalés au
rang d'incidents comme les minutes de
silence non respecté comme des propos
antisémites parfois même lorsque ces
incidents relèvent de l'apologie du
terrorisme certaines alliances se font
sur des bases idéologiques avec une
vision fantasmée de la société et dans
le cadre d'un projet politique assumé
mais les alliances et les comportements
collaborationnistes que soutendent ces
pactes sont effectués pour beaucoup par
l'âcheté c'est bien la volonté de mourir
vieux qui sanctifie cette union au nom
du mourir vieux on se rallie à celui qui
menace de mourir jeune et qui envoie
aussi sa jeunesse mourir à sa place au
nom du mourir vieux on préfère aller
jusqu'à la délation pour poer son
allégeance au nom du mourir vieux on
préfère accepter toutes les
compromissions et les soumissions qui en
découlent pour un mourir vieux dans
l'espoir de voir un jour un vivre mieux
on finit par accepter que d'autres et
notamment notre jeunesse vivent mal et
périssent jeune certains voudraient
vivre vieux dans un monde inhumain là où
l'on vivra la peur au ventre quotidienne
inquiet d'être le prochain sur leur
liste certains voudraient vivre vieux en
uvrant à se placer en dernier sur leur
liste des menacés de mort quit à
participer aux exactions mais à
tellement vouloir mourir vieux on finit
surtout par mourir seul car il ne reste
plus personne pour protester à
[Applaudissements]
tous à tous ceux qui savent mais qui ne
veulent pas voir je dis qu'il vaut mieux
que ça soit dur à voir plutôt que dur à
vivre et à ces gens qui sont fiers qui
ne dissimulent pas leur crime et qui ne
veulent rien de ce qu'on leur offre on
ne peut plus leur répondre avec une
France qui n'est plus rien si on veut
vraiment rebattent les cartes on ne se
tient jamais droit dans des pantoufles
merci de votre
[Applaudissements]
attention
merci michaell pati
merci nos communes nos villes vivent et
vibre au rythme de la nation au rythme
du monde et dans un instant on va
évoquer l'action internationale de
solidité des m de France dans un instant
après avoir entendu ce message tellement
fort tellement humain tellement et bien
qui correspond au message aussi qui est
porté par les élus locaux et par les
responsables des
[Musique]
communes voilà vous avez entendu à
l'instant la prise de parole le discours
de Michell Paty he qui s'est exprimé
lors de cette hommage qui a été rendu à
Samuel Paty son frère qui a été
assassiné et auquel se mélange et bien
également la mémoire aujourd'hui de
Dominique Bernard donc deux enseignants
qui ont été victimes du
terrorisme vous avez pu voir et bien
l'émotion hein notamment des maires des
édyes qui sont aujourd'hui rassemblé en
cette séance de clôture du 105e congrès
de l'Association des maire de France
dans un instant et bien une autre
séquence d'émotion une autre séquence
forte car l'association des maires de
France prévoit aussi d'exprimer sa
solidarité à l'égard de la population de
l'Arménie alors que le hautkarabak est
passé au mois de septembre au mains de
l'Azerbaïdjan 100000 réfugiés ont fui
déjà et bien l'an dernier David lissnard
appelait les communes de France à se
mobiliser pour témoigner de leur soutien
à l'Arménie et dans un instant et bien
les maires vont également recevoir un
l'ambassadrice d'Arménie pour évoquer ce
sujet euh mais en attendant sur ce
plateau et bien Stéphane Vernet est
resté avec nous merci beaucoup Stéphane
d'être avec nous pour être là et
commenter et bien cette séance de
clôture du 105e congrès de l'Association
des mares de France et Catherine tricot
est avec nous direct actrice de la revue
regard bonjour Catherine bonjour votre
sentiment après ce moment un moment
d'émotion un moment d'émotion aussi avec
une prise de parole à la fois forte et
très politique on l'a entendu oui en
effet c'est une prise de position qui ne
mâchait pas ses mots on va dire je pense
que elle a sa place dans un congrès
comme celui-ci le Congrès des mères
parce qu'au quotidien ce sont des élus
qui vont chercher
à faire une faire unité c'estàd
rassembler
leurs concitoyens et au quotidien ça va
vouloir ça va se traduire par exemple
par la prise en charge de la mémoire
dans une diversité il y a les grands
moments de la mémoire nationale qui sont
toujours commémorés par les maires et
puis localement ils vont s'attacher à
revivifier une mémoire qui peut être
celle de d'un problème dans une école
d'une communauté de la ville et c'est me
semble être dans leur fonction et très
fondamental pour notre unité nationale
on va continuer à parler de ce sujet
mais je vous le disais à l'instant et
bien c'est asmic Thalan ambassadrice
d'Arménie qui s'exprime dans cette
séquence d'hommage à l'Arménie fait ici
à l'Arménie et peut-être plus que
l'honneur l'expression d'une réelle
amitié et d'un soutien
sincère c'est un grand privilège mais
aussi une occasion unique pour exprimer
la très profonde reconnaissance de
l'Arménie au ma aux élus français pour
l'extraordinaire soutien de solidarité
qu'il témoigne à notre peuple qui
traverse un moment crucial de son
histoire des centaines de collectivités
de toute taille et dans la grande
diversité se sont engagé à l'unisson
depuis 3 ans et à travers des
expressions multiples dans le soutien du
ha garabak et de
l'Arménie je souhaite saisir cette
occasion pour réaffirmer notre gratitude
à toutes les collectivités pour des vœux
résolutions motions qu'elles ont adopté
pour dénoncer la guerre d'agression de
l'Azerbaïdjan son entreprise délibérée
de nettoyage ethnique au haut karabach
l'exode forcé de sa population
autochtone la politique de destruction
de ces terr arméniennees ancestrale
l'effacement de son patrimoine culturel
historique ainsi que les menaces répété
contre le territoire souverain de
l'Arménie cette mobilisation massive des
élus locaux a été prolongée par les
votes d'abord au Sénat puis à
l'Assemblée
nationale cette solidarité exceptionnel
exprimé quasi unanimement et
collectivement par le peuple français
traduit le soutien à un pays proche un
peuple ami qui incarne au milieu au
milieu des empires autoritaires qui
l'entourent les valeurs de tolérance et
de
démocratie car les Français incarnent
plus que toute autre nation cet esprit
de justice et d'humanité cet attachement
profond à la liberté et à la fraternité
qui partout dans le monde confère à la
France ce supplément d'âme qui fait tout
son prestige et sa gloire c'est aussi je
crois un soutien au nom du
responsabilité universelle à l'égard
d'un peuple qui fut le victime du
premier génocide du 20e
siècle cette solidarité entière du
peuple français témoigne également des
sentiments profonds d'amitié qui
trouvent leurs sources dans les liens
très anciens qui entre nos deux nations
dès le royaume arménien de silici il y a
près de 1000 ans une amitié renforcée
par le temps et par les épreuves partagé
et jalonné de dates et de symboles
forts la présence de ces notaves du
dernier roi arménien Léon 5 Lusignan
dans la nécropole royale de la basilique
du Saint-Denis au côté des rois de
France la fraternité d'armes lors de
l'héroïque bataille de mousadag et le
sauvetage des 4500 Arméniens par la
marine française en 1915 ou encore
l'héroïsme de missac manouian qui fera
prochainement son entrée au pantthéon
le seul étranger au côté des grands
hommes de France sont autant de symboles
qui nous
unissent cette amitié millénaire fut
nourrie et enrichie par la présence et
l'action de la communauté arménienne de
France constitué essentiellement des
descendants des rescapés du génocide en
1915 remarquablement intégré fier d'être
français à 100 % tout en restant fidèle
à ses racine et à son identité d'origine
Charles Aznavour m manouian Patrick de
Van Henri Verneuil Michel le grand
vanque berberrian et bien d'autres sont
devenus à la fois des artisans des
porte-paroles et des symboles de cette
amitié qu'il me soit brièvement permis
d'insister sur le rôle ins signe qu'on
jouit les collectivité locale et
territoriale dans l'amitié
exceptionnelle et les relations
privilégiées qui lit l'Arménie et la
France en paraphrasant tofil qui disait
que c'est dans la commune que réside la
force des peuples libres je crois
pouvoir affirmer que c'est dans les
communes que réside la force et le
dynamisme humain incroyable qui nourrit
et irrigue l'amitié
franco-arménienne les communes
françaises avaient tissé des liens de
jumelage avec les villes arméniennes
avant même que l'Arménie retrouve son
indépendance et avant même que les
relations d'état à état puissent être
noué entre nos deux pays les villes
françaises ont été aussi en première
ligne à l'initiative de chak Shirak à
leur maire de Paris pour soutenir notre
aspiration de construire un État libre
démocratique et
indépendant ce sont encore les communes
qui s'étaient engagé pleinement au côté
de la population du haut garabach au
travers des dizaines de chars d'amitié
pour briser son isolement imposé par
l'Azerbaïdjan il y a quelques mois les
collectivités territoriales dans toute
leur diversité ont essayé de conduire à
l'initiative de la mère de Paris à
nidalgo un convoi human ire au ha
garabak pour apporter de l'aide à sa
population asphamée suite à un blocus
total de 10
mois depuis environ 150 ans notre
vieille nation est victime d'une haine
tenace rabique littéralement d'une forme
orientale d'antisémitisme de la part de
ses voisins turques et azerbaïdjanais
qui selon leurs propres mots se
conçoivent comme une nation au sein de
deux états et qui ne cachent pas leurs
ambitions de finir le travail de 1915
donc de parachever l'épuration ethnique
des Arméniens entamé par le génocide
l'épuration ethnique du arabar qui s'est
achevée en septembre dernier n'est que
la plus récente
séquelle la plus récente mais pas
nécessairement la dernière tant la
menace
perdure aujourd'hui le régime
azerbaïdjanais revendique explicitement
le sud de l'Arménie et même sa capitale
yelevan autrement dit toute
l'Arménie face au défis immense
existentiel auquel nous faisons face et
pour que la disparition d'une nation et
d'une civilisation plusieurs fois
millénair ne soit pas une fatalité
inéluctable nous avons besoin de votre s
soutien fidèle fort et continu
multiplier les jumelages entre les
communes françaises et arméniennes
permettrait d'inscrire ce soutien dans
la durée au-delà du soutien et plus que
soutien il s'agira pour les 71 communes
arméniennes de protection grâce au
jumelage massif grâce au lien d'amitié
et de solidarité multiple les 100000
déplacés de force du Gabach également se
sentiront moins seul au monde
retrouveront avec un peu un peu plus
d'espoir et de sentiments de
réconfort nous pouvons également faire
connaître mieux nos cultures et nos
peuples respectifs par des jumelages des
écoles des voyages scolaires des
journées d'Arménie dans les communes
françaises et des journées de France
dans les communes arméniennes à cet
effet je souhaite exprimer mes très
chaleureux remerciements à David Lisnard
pour la semaine culturelle arménienne
que la ville de can accueillira à son
initiative en février prochain avec une
programmation artistique
exceptionnelle merci cher
[Applaudissements]
David et s'il m'est permis de formuler
un vœ c'est qu'à côté des liens
culturels se développent également des
projets de coopération économique les
communes qui s'y intéressent peuvent
bénéficier de soutien de nos deux États
respectifs qui se sont engagés
effectivement à travers la feuille de
route de coopération économique
franco-arménienne d'encourager les
contacts entre les villes et la et les
coopérations décentralisées qui
participereront au renforcement de nos
relations
économiques je souhaite enfin exprimer
ma reconnaissance aux communes qui ont
souhaiter baptiser des places des rues
des parcs et des jardins au nom de
l'Arménie de l'artzar au garabak au nom
des personnalités franco-arméniennes qui
ont fait la France qui sont devenus des
visages de la France et qui incarnent
une part importante de notre
amitié l'inauguration de l'explanade de
l'Arménie à Paris place de l' place de
l'artzard à Valence des parcs place rue
et promenade à Marseille Lyon
Montpellier canne Grenoble Nice
exant-provence ClermontFerrand nî Clichy
clamar Draguignan ville franchursonne
ville urbane et cette liste est loin
d'être exhaustive sont des gestes forts
de solidarité et de
reconnaissance monsieur le Président
cher David Lisnard l'année dernière
quand l'Arménie était agressée sur son
sol vous avez invité les communes
publiquement au nom du Bureau de
l'Association des maires de France à se
mobiliser pour témoigner de leur soutien
à
l'Arménie je souhaite vous en réaffirmer
encore mare sincère gratitude et vous
[Applaudissements]
dire
et vous dire combien l'engagement
continue de l'Association des mares de
France de toutes les communes françaises
demeure précieux pour l'Arménie et c'est
avec plaisir que je saisis cette
occasion pour vous exprimer mes
chaleureuses félicitations à l'occasion
de votre
réélection la présence de la France des
élus à nos côtés est vital pour que dans
cette région du monde où l'Arménie
représente la véritable frontière
sud-orientale de l'EUR Europe le dernier
rempart avant les fondamentalismes et
les empires les choc guetes de
l'Occident comme le dit syvant Tesson ou
l'anomalie
démocratique que ce message
d'universalisme d'humanisme de tolérance
et d'esprit de paix incarné par
l'Arménie puisse continuer à être porté
merci encore de m'avoir donné la parole
devant vous et un immense merci surtout
de votre solidarité vive la France et
vive
l'Arménie
[Applaudissements]
merci asmic tomalgion merci Madame
l'ambassadeur de la République
[Applaudissements]
d'Arménie et nous allons maintenant dans
un instant passer à la partie conclusive
de ce congrès des maires et de C pour ce
discours de ambassadrice
d'Arménie on voit dans cette séquence
Stéphane et bien l'importance qu' a
aujourd'hui et bien la situation
internationale même pour nos élus locaux
une situation il n'y a pas que l'Arménie
bien sûr on pense bien sûr au conflit
aujourd'hui au Proche Orient qui
ressurgit un petit peu partout en France
et qui contribue notamment à fracturer
notre
société oui tout à fait alors moi j'égir
peu je pense qu'en fait il y a on est
rentré dans une période où tout le monde
a bien compris que ce qui se passe au
bout du monde peut avoir des
conséquences directes un impact immédiat
sur notre vie
quotidienne dans des délais très courts
et ça je je pense que cette cette cette
ce phénomène il a été il s'est très
fortement accentué il il est très marqué
depuis le covid covid c'est une épidémie
qui démar en Chine qui met le pays à
l'arrêt on a eu la guerre en Ukraine
avec un impact imédiia sur les prix des
carburants du gaz et cetera des
problématiques d'électricité enfin on a
des choses très très très très
conséquentes sur notre sur notre vie
quotidienne vous avez toute la rhtorique
sur le réchauffement climatique où on
voit que bah aujourd'hui le
réchauffement climatique ça ça impacte
très
fortement le le le pays c'est pas que
c'est pas que c'est pas qu'autour de
l'équateur ou ailleurs et cetera on voit
bien et les inondations les incendies il
y a 2
ans enfin on voit bien que les les
l'impact est MDI il y compris sur le sur
la pression migratoire les nouveaux flux
enfin voilà euh
le le conflit au prochorient
euh donne une nouvelle dimension à ce à
ce à cette problématique parce qu'il y a
cette espèce de peur de la d'importation
du conflit le le fait qu'on on sent
qu'on a une société qui est en train de
se cristalliser ou comme si chacun était
sommé de choisir son camp c'est ça ça
fait un peu écho au discours de de de
Michel si sur le 8 mai parce que c'est
un discours très fort mais plus que fort
c'est un discours dur c pas un discours
d'apaisement en fait hein en disant
voilà il faut il faut il faut s'engager
très fermement mais ça veut dire il faut
aussi choisir son camp et d'une manière
générale il y a tout un tas de choses
qui se passent en dehors de nos
frontières mais qui ont des
répercussions immédiates sur ce qu'on
vit ici et y compris dans notre
quotidien donc oui ça ça a du sens ça a
du sens pour les mares parce que parce
que comme ça se passe au niveau du
quotidien la proximité B eux peuvent
avoir des retours de des retours de
flamme surtout sur tous ces points-l oui
oui Catherine tricot effectivement le
Mondial ressurgit au niveau local et un
petit peu partout dans notre vie même
quotidienne aujourd'hui et
singulièrement pour les maires tout tout
à fait ce que vous venez de dire à
l'instant sur les les impacts directs
dans notre vie quotidienne mais aussi
dans notre représentation de de notre
monde il y a une conséquence directe et
les les mares sont en première place par
exemple de nombreux maires valorisent
par exemple la diversité dans leur
villes en parlant euh du nombre de
langues que l'on parle dans dans la
ville en faisant valoir euh toutes les
communautés qui sont présentes avec des
manifestations autour de leur
participation à la vie communale euh on
voit bien aussi que euh ce sont des gens
qui vont chercher à trouver des
solutions par exemple par rapport au
réchauffement climatique par rapport à
l'accueil des migrants ce sont euh des
gens qui vont être qui vont chercher à
créer l'unité de leur collectif de la de
la commune dans lequelle ils sont euh le
par lesquel ils ont été élus et s'ils
sont aussi appréciés c'est probablement
parce que à la fois ce sont des
personnes politiques donc qui ont des
engagements politiques mais qui vont
chercher au-delà de leur engagement une
manière de maintenir la collectivité à
travers des actions concrètes ou des
actions symboliques qui vont nous nous
relier tandis que l'on voit arriver à
ellizabeth Borne vous la voyez la
première ministre qui va s'installer
hein cela alors que on est donc donc à
ce moment de clôture de ce 105e congrès
des maires de France avec toute une
séquence qui va s'ouvrir avec et bien le
vice-président André lénal qui va
s'exprimer et puis vous pourrez entendre
David Lisnard et ellisabeth borne qui
vont aussi parler bien sûr tout à
l'heure on va pouvoir suivre tout cela
en direct et en intégralité d'ici
maintenant quelques
minutes Stéphane vous parliez tout à
l'heure he effectivement du discours de
Michel Patti qui a été un discours
offensif et dur assez clivant on va en
écouter un extrait tout de
suite cela conforte mes propos tenu en
mai dernier dans la revue humanisme où
je mettais l'accent sur les limites de
l'efficacité du devoir de mémoire les
hommages nous préservent de la
coutumance qui mène une forme de
collaborationisme et conforte notre
aspiration à l'humanisme par peur de
devenir inhumain à notre tour la
violence de la résurgence de
l'antisémitisme le 8 mai qui accompagne
si souvent les commentaires sur la
violence islamiste démontre que le
devoir de mémoire est certes nécessaire
mais en aucun cas suffisant pour nous
immuniser contre l'aveuglement et les
dangers qui nous menacent le devoir de
mémoire donne le sentiment de faire ce
qui doit être fait tout en produisant en
effet perverse dévastateur l'émergence
de la
victimisation on a toujours voulu
opposer les lumières à l'obscurantisme
il me semble bien naïf de penser que
l'inhumain surgit par carence
d'humanisme en réalité l'inhumain par
définition rejette l'humanisme il me
semble également nié de croire que si on
fait preuve de plus de bienveillance en
se soumettant aux exigences de
l'inhumain il renoncera à ses projets
macabres la bienveillance est ainsi
utilisée comme régulateur de l'humeur de
la bienpensance offrant à ses tenants un
anxioliique naturel qui s'appelle le
déni et finit par anesthésier toute
capacité de voir le mal mais également
le le bien Catherine ça vous fait réagir
hein ce discours oui parce qu'en fait je
vois pas très bien où ça nous emmène
refuser la bien la bienveillance par
exemple quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'on se mette en guerre les uns contre
les autres quelle est la quelle est
l'alternative que qu'elle nous propose
nous sommes d'appartenir un un camp un C
de la lumière face à
l'obscurantismeoui mais d'abord la
lumière et la lumière l'obscurantisme
n'apparaît pas de rien et la lumière ça
se travaille ça se construit ça
s'élargit ça se partage et moi ce que je
ressens dans ce discours évidemment
comme c'est la sœur de Samuel Paty on a
envie de on n pas envie d'être dur avec
ce qu'elle dit parce que on comprend on
se met à sa place enfin je veux dire on
souffre avec elle donc on comprend d'où
ça vient on comprend mais mais
parfaitement parfaitement et je et et
vraiment enfin on a tous été absolument
bouleversés par cet assassinat euh mais
la réponse c'est la réponse ne peut pas
être de rechercher dès l'enfance parce
que dans le dans la suite de son
discours elle dit en fait euh mais
c'est pas la peine d'avoir de la
bienveillance avec ses jeunes avec ses
enfants mais non moi ce que je crois
c'est que c'est il faut leur le leur
donner la main pour les emmener sur un
autre chemin ne pas les laisser
s'embarquer et ce que je crois ici à
l'association des mares de France c'est
que bien des mares justement vont faire
ce travail pour parler à tous pour
embarquer tous pour laisser tout le
monde pour mettre tout le monde dans
notre République commune et et en fait
je je j'avoue être troublé parce qu'elle
a eu des mots très très dur à l'égard
des pacifistes par exemple elle a eu des
mots très durs à l'égard des de la
communauté homosexuelle enfin mais
pourquoi enfin je ne comprends pas on va
pas se mettre tous en guerre on va pas
se mettre tous en guerre les uns contre
les autres de manière préventive en plus
c'estàd que c'est même avant même
d'avoir d'avoir agi qu'il faudrait déjà
être en défiance non je crois qu'il y a
pas d'autre solution que de rester des
gens du côté des lumières des gens du
côté de l'humanisme et des gens du côté
de la bienveillance en tout cas ce que
l'on voit à travers ce discours et c'est
ce dont nous parlions euh tout à l'heure
hein effectivement c'est la façon dont
dont les grands conflits internationaux
ressurgissent dans le débat français
avec notamment et bien ce à quoi faisait
allusion Michael Patti le la résurgence
de de
l'antisémitisme voilà toutes ces choses
que l'on a vu tout au long du mois
d'octobre et qui pour le coup a pu se
voir dans l'espace public a pu voilà on
en revient à notre sujet aussi et bien
la la place des maires dans tout
cela mais c'est-à-dire que quand elle
quand elle dénonce le le 8 mai elle a
complètement raison je veux dire voilà
fa elle dénonce les accommodement quoi
non mais c'est elle parle de dénis
d'aveuglement le le le le le Wien n'a
pas droit de séance quand vous êtes face
à des attentats particulièrement sauvage
barbare et cetera conduit au nom d'une
édologie islamiste là il y a aucune
question à se poser et en fait le le le
la dénonciation et le rejet et
l'antisémitisme et de toute forme de
racisme et et et de et de et de et de et
de l'islamisme il il ne il ne se discute
pas c'est enfin je veux dire il y a pas
de voilà il y a pas de et on voit bien
que derrière quand elle quand elle parle
de dénis et d'aveuglement euh elle
pointe le wisme et cetera enfin on
bascule sur un propos euh très politique
en réalité euh et euh et qui qui va pas
qui ne va pas dans le sens de de
l'apaisement c'est ce que je c'est ce
que je c'est ce que je disais tout
àheure je P d'accord aussi non mais
alors sans sans le nommer je pense que
en fait elle a elle a aussi dans le
collimateur tout tout le comportement de
la France insoumise mais ça c'est un
autre débat on va pas on va pas y
revenir d'utant qu'elle les a pas cité
mais je pense que voilà c'était c'était
clairement identifié clairement ciblé
juste pour juste pour terminer Catherine
là je vous rejoins tout à fait Catherine
c'est que pour les mères la
problématique c'est aussi celle du du
vivre ensemble au cotidien et en fait
dans la séquence dans ce qu'on est en
train de vivre en ce moment c'est euh
c'est un peu le bout du bout de de ce
fameux vivre ensemble qui a été quelque
chose qui a été porté au nu très
développé et cetera qui était qui était
une rhétorique de des socialistes quand
ils étaient au pouvoir et cetera et euh
et je je pense aussi qu'on est en terme
de modèle de société et de
fonctionnement on est on est on est on
est au bout de ce ce ce système qui se
voulait très ouvert inclusif et et
généreux et que on est quand même dans
une société qui parle bien des aspects
et en train de se communautariser donc
toutes ces questions là les mairres ils
les vivent au quotidien elles se posent
elles se posent de manière très forte
mais mais c'est
pas c'est pas en exigeant des gens de
choisir un camp et cetera et de se et de
et de renoncer à toute bienveillance par
exemple qu'on arrivera à qu'on arrivera
à mettre de l'huile dans les rouages je
pense que c'est le contraire
effectivement oui Catherine oui que j'ai
bien entendu comme vous la mise en cause
de la France insoumise que j'ai tr trouv
un tout petit peu exagéré parce que de
faire CIT pas c elle ne les a pas cité
mais c'était bien ça qu'on entendait et
je trouve que c'est très exagéré parce
que il y a pas évidemment de connivance
de la France insoumise avec les
assassins de Samuel Patti avec
l'assassin de Samuel Paty elle le laisse
entendre et je trouve que c'est pour ça
qu'elle enfin je comprends sa douleur
mais parfois peut-être que ça l'embarque
quoi mais l'autre chose que vous dites
quand vous dites on est dans un moment
où notre société peut-être que le vivre
ensemble les mères sont devant cette
difficulté de continuer de le faire
vivre et je crois que c'est vrai le
problème c'est que il ne faut pas y
renoncer moi je ne crois pas qu'il y a
une alternative à une société dans
lequel on on vit ensemble ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est de
porter le bon diagnostic sur qu'est-ce
qui est en train de mettre en cause ce
vivre ensemble et dans les éléments à
mon avis de qui remettent en cause ce
vivre ensemble je pense que le le la
l'appauvrissement des services public le
fractionnement des territoires voire la
ségrégation territoriale je pense que ça
ce sont vraiment euh
des réalités qui s'inscrivent dans le
quotidien de chacun et qui font vivre
profondément le sentiment d'être
discriminé d'être des sous-citoyens et
que ça ça c'est c'est un ferment alors
et c'est pas ça ne concerne pas que les
banlieux ça ne concerne pas que les
habitants des quartiers populaires ça
concerne aussi les tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui n'arrivent pas à avoir un
médecin pour se soigner qui sont trop
loin enfin ce sentiment que ce qui nous
unissait c'était le fait que le timbre
poste il était unique et que tout le
monde avait droit au même service la
lettre elle partait et 24 heures après
elle était arrivée à sa destination
quelle qu'elle soit et que il y avait
cette cette unité du territoire et cette
unité du service public qui s'est défait
et je pense que enfin moi j'ai le le
l'intuition très profonde et les maires
sont face à cette question là c'est que
sans un un retour d'une unité de des
services publics d'une qualité de
service public qui soit homogène au pays
et qui corresponde à la qualité attendue
parce que des sous services publics ça
va pas faire la rue Michel he explique
vous dites quoi l'exaspération des
administrés une partie de la violence
que l'on ressent dans notre société
aussi vis-à-vis des élus locaux ben
c'est-à-dire c'est c'est le sentiment ce
que je dire c'est le sentiment de ne
plus qu'est-ce qui nourrit le sentiment
de ne plus être tous ensemble à égalité
et et cette cette à mon sens ce que
cette cette disparition du sentiment de
cocitoyenneté d'égalité elle est
notamment nourrie par le réel qui est
des différents de traitement et de vie
qui sont très insupportables dans notre
dans notre histoire nationale c'est tous
les pays n'ont pas liberté égalité
fraternité comme devise mais nous c'est
la nôtre et le maire du coup est le
support de beaucoup de frustration parce
que c'est aussi lui l'élu le plus proche
aujourd'hui Stéphane Vernet oui c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire
que effectivement c'est le c'est c'est
le le maire pour beaucoup de gens qui
incarne qui incarne l'État qui incarne
l'autorité publique qui voilà qui qui va
devenir l'espèce de Bou de Bou émissaire
le réceptacle de tout et qui se fait
alpaguer y compris des choses pour
lesquelles il est absolument pas
responsable il est pas concerné j'aime
bien cette notion de je je suis
complètement d'accord avec ce que vient
de dire Catherine j'aime j'aime bien
cette en même temps quand je vous écoute
j'ai l'impression que tout est la faute
de la poste qui a supprimé le table
rouge non pas du tout c c'était une
image c'est mais c'est une excellente
image c'est un très c'est un excellent
symbole parce que parce que ce que vous
pointez est tout à fait vrai et en plus
je peux vous dire que le la suppression
ou je je on enriicane mais enfin
j'enricane mais je je je suis très
coupable parce que je peux vous dire que
dans les dans les dans les campagnes et
CETA dans les zones rurales et sur dans
la dans la vraie vie ça s'est pas passé
du tout ça a été très très très très mal
vécu parce que vous avez raison c'est
une rupture d'égalité des services moi
j'ajouterais dans ces problématiques qui
font que il y a il y a enfin par rapport
à notre devise Liberté Égalité
Fraternité il y a il y a un vrai
problème de fond il y a aussi la mise en
panne de l'ascenseur sociale h il y a
une génération après guerre en fait où
le le comment le le le le on avait
besoin on avait besoin de reconstruire
le pays on avait besoin de former plein
de gens pour des tas de métiers et
cetera et là ça été l'ascenseur social
il a il a fonctionné mais de manière
merveilleuse à plein hein vous aviez des
des des des des fils de paysans des
filles d'ouvriers et cetera qui
faisaient des études et qui ont fait des
très brillantes carrières et qui on qui
qui là il y a il s'est passé quelque
chose mais depuis les années 80 on va
dire euh depuis le le chômage de masse
depuis voilà il y a le le ça ne
fonctionne plus du tout et vous avez là
il y a une il y a une rupture et
aujourd'hui pour boucler la boucle par
rapport à à la thématique que vous
évoquez c'est-à-dire la situation
internationale et ses conséquences on
vit dans une dans une séquence où je
pense qu'il y a énormément d'angoisse
cumulé et que la peur du déclassement
n'a jamais été aussi forte et qu'elle
joue énormément dans les rapports
sociaux aujourd'hui je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que vous dites et ce
que je pense c'est qu' on ne peut pas
simplement mobiliser le souvenir des
tres glorieuses c'estàd qu'on ne
reviendra pas à cette période-là et le
l'ascenseur social comme vous dites en
fait il était collectif c'est toute la
société qui s'est qui s'est élevé et qui
a qui a un certain confort et et une
dignité nouvelle et cetera et
aujourd'hui ce que je pense c'est qu'on
ne peut pas simplement vouloir mobiliser
et revenir à cela c'estàdire qu'il
s'agit de de de construire un objectif
collectif qui serait grand et et qui
mobiliserait les imaginaires euh les les
ambitions de chacun et probablement que
ça ne peut pas être de continuer à
élever simplement le niveau de vie et le
pouvoir d'achat et cetera il faut qu'on
ait des objectifs communs et
probablement moi c'est en tout cas mon
intuition c'est que le combat contre le
réchauffement climatique et pour la
biodiversité et probablement le combat
fédérateur qui permettrait de d'emmener
tout le monde vers quelque chose de de
voilà de de de grand de fédérateur de
fédérateurs de grands qui qui a du sens
et qui offre une autre perspective que
simplement la R réussite individuelle
qui se traduirait par plus d'argent et
ben chacun son diagnostic he puisque
hier et bien Emmanuel Macron devant les
maires est aussi allé et bien sur ce
sujet pour lui aucune promesse ne pourra
être tenue si la bataille du plein
emploi pour le coup n'est pas gagner
écoutez le président de la République la
souveraineté agricole
industrielle la création d'emploi sur
nos territoires et la bataille du plein
emploi qui est indispensable sinon
aucune des promesses qu'on vous fait ne
sera
parce que le seul moyen de pouvoir
réinvestir sur nos services publics de
vous accompagner c'est de gagner la
bataille du plein emploi ah voilà le
plein emploi le plein emploi le plein
emploi bon là on entend des des refrains
classiques bien sûr d'Emmanuel Macron à
un moment où en plus et bien il y a une
petite une petite hausse une petite
stagnation au niveau du chômage je
rigole parce que il a commencé son
discours non pas en disant le plein
emploi le plein emploi le plein emploi
il a commencé son discours en disant la
sécurité la sécurité la sécurité vrai
mais bon voilà non non oui pour en fait
c'est la mère des batailles pour
Emmanuel Macron et c'est c'est le c'est
le c'est c'est le fil rouge qu'il a
donné à son quinena à ces deux
quinquenas j'ai envie de vous dire voilà
et
la il dit ouis on on ne pourra rien on
pourra pas vous accompagner et on pourra
pas on pourra pas acquérir cette cette
fameuse restaurer les services publics
si on arrive pas au plein emploi parce
qu'il a une vision des choses qui
consistent à dire que le plein emploi
permettrait de redresser les comptes euh
de la France d'amener des gens dans les
territoires dans les usines si on
réussit la la réindustrialisation donc
ça veut dire permettre de d'avoir à
nouveau des enfants dans les écoles et
donc on peut rouvrir des pharmacies des
restaurants que sais-je
enfin trouver des solutions à toutes les
choses qui posent problèm dans les zones
rurales notamment mais pas que mais
surtout dans les zones rurales depuis
depuis des années bon c'est sa vision
c'est sa c'est sa c'est sa vision des
choses le problème c'est
que ce qu'il exprime là il l'exprime au
moment même
où ce Paris qu'il avait fait autour du
plein emploi est en train de marquer le
part oui oui effectivement c'est ce
qu'on disait les chiffres du chômage
sont un petit peu moins bons pour le le
président de la République bon Emmanuel
Macron que l'on a vu donc s'exprimer
longuement à l'Élysée bon on lui a fait
tout un petit procès autour de de son
absence dans cette enceinte même du
Congrès des Maires alors la réponse de
l'Élysée ça a été aussi que c'est parce
que son entourage estime que David
lissnard qui vient d'être réélu à la
tête de l'Association des maires de
France politise aujourd'hui le Congrès
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Catherine
tricot
oui je pense que c'est vrai qui politise
mais lui-même que ne le fait-il non mais
que ne le fait-il je veux dire il peut
venir parler et avoir un un discours je
ne enfin je ne crois pas qu'il puisse
continuer de penser que il peut se
mettre en dehors du monde et de ses
batailles il pense qu'il n'a pas sa
place dans une manifest sttion qui est
contre l'antisémitisme il pense qu'il ne
doit pas venir à l'Association des
maires de France je pense qu'il se
trompe je pense que Emmanuel Macron et
le le le président de la République ça
n'en fait pas moins un quelqu'un qui a
apporté un discours et un discours qui
doit être un discours politique et qui
doit être soumis à
discussion contradiction éventuellement
voilà et moi je je ne n'entends pas tout
à fait cette excuse comme une excuse
valable d'autant que pendant ce temps-là
d'autres produisent des discours euh bon
je pense notamment à à sa plus sa rivale
la plus solide actuellement qui est
l'extrême droite et Marine Le Pen et je
trouve qu'il ne produit pas de discours
vous avez rappelé que il a commencé par
dire sécurité sécurité sécurité non mais
enfin je veux dire qu'est-ce qu'il
produit comme discours pour faire face à
à à aux thématiques qui sont portées par
l'extrême droite que ce soit sur la
sécurité sur l'immigration et qui
fracture la France il a un devoir à mon
sens de porter de de porter une
proposition qui réunisse la France et ce
qu'il ce qu'il renonce à faire j'avoue
que je ne me l'explique pas alors on
attend le discours de clôture de David
Lisnard qui doit s'exprimer d'ici
quelques minutes David Lisnard qui a été
réélu sans surprise à la tête de
l'Association des maires de France
Stéphane il y avait pas d'autres
candidats il faut le dire quelle stature
ça ça lui confèire à David lissnard
aujourd'hui bah le être président des
des maires de France
c'est c'est c'est un c'est comment c'est
une position qui est quand même très en
vue et euh et et très enviable parce que
moi je je suis d'accord avec l'idée que
le mandat de maire c'est le plus ha des
mandats enfin il me semble hein mais bon
après je suis pas poque je fais pas de
politique et tout ça mais il me semble
que c'est c'est c'est quand même celui
qui est le plus en proximité qui auquel
ça rest l'él préféré des Français hein
même si on a bien compris il a être le
président la principale association
d'élus qui regroupe l'essentiel des
maires de France euh oui ça lui ça lui
confère un ça lui donne une envergure
euh intéressante après est-ce qu'il
est-ce qu'il politise le Congrès euh moi
je je saurais pas répondre à cette à
cette question là je trouve que le je
trouve que la l'explication qui est
fournie par l'entourage du du président
de la République me paraît un peu un peu
courte est-ce que David Lisnard a des
ambitions pour 2027 euh oui certainement
je pense est-ce il devient une voix
montante à droite en tout cas et VO
est-ce est-ce qu'il utilise
l'Association des Maires euh comme
marche-pied je sais pas françois Barouin
était très très neutre son prédécesseur
était très très neutre en la matière
peut-être que David nisnar est les moins
c'est possible après j'ai envie de vous
dire bah il vient d'être élu mais faute
de combattant voilà liste unique il
était tout seul à se présenter c'est
aussi parce qu'il fait il fait
l'unanimité et puis parce qu'il y a il y
a peut-être un détail de enfin je c'est
pas un détail mais il y a peut-être un
point qui vudrait aborder c'est que euh
comment
el Macron il a été élu il y a plus de 6
ans euh il a été réélu en 2027 en 2022
pardon je m'emelle dans les dates euh
mais en 6 ans en fait le le son parti ou
son mouvement a été incapable de s'en
crré dans les territoires je veux dire
s'il y a pas s'il y a pas de
contrreeliste et cetera et s y a c'est
qu'il y a aucune possibilité pour la
majorité présidentielle de devenir une
majorité municipale je veux dire enfin
il y a il y a y a il y a il y a rien ils
sont enfin ça si c'est un s s'il a bien
un échec retentissant éclatant et
phénoménal de d'Emmanuel Macron au cours
de au cours de de ces 6 années c'est
l'incapacité totale à construire un
mouvement qui qui qui arrive à
s'emplinter dans les territoires et à et
à et à convaincre et à convaincre les
électeurs à l'échelon à l'échelon local
de lui faire confiance ça n'a pas marché
on va écouter justement un petit passage
de de David Lisnard qui s'est exprimé
lors de de l'ouverture de de cette
séance on écoute de quel état d'esprit
dans quel état d'esprit vous abordez ce
congrès bien nous l'abordons avec la
volonté de faire en sorte que la
République française ne soit pas une
abstraction que nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants puissent vivre dans un
pays qui rejette toute forme d'exclusion
de l'autre à priori toute forme
d'antisémitisme de racisme toute
violence bref je crois que nous
ressentons bien que nous sommes à une
époque particulièrement grave et face à
cette époque
dans cette époque de ce contexte le
pouvoir local est une des solutions
alors et et d'ailleurs je je veux dire
je veux dire je remercier je vous
remercier de de de votre présence
remercier Christophe Béchu le ministre
notre ministreis dire de tutelle c'est
un mot qu'on qu'on aime pas mais le
ministre qui nous accompagne au
quotidien avec qui on bosse et euh dire
que ce congrès ça va être le Congrès des
alertes le Congrès parfois des
dénonciations mais aussi le Congrès des
solutions et ça nous y tenons absolument
avec 15 ministres qui vont participer à
nos travaux la première ministre qui
sera présente une interaction avec
l'exécutif on veut stimuler stimuler la
République française on entend David
lissnard qui insiste he sur le fait
qu'il va y avoir toute une partie du
gouvernement et ça a été le cas qui est
venu à ce congrès c'est aussi une façon
de vouloir faire taire les tensions dont
on parle beaucoup entre et bien
l'Association des maires de France et le
gouverne
dire bon on arrive à travailler quand
même avec le gouvernement il y a pas un
si gros yatus avec l'exécutif oui moi je
crois qu'il a de toute façon c'est sa
fonction de président de l'association
des mères de France de toute manière de
d'aplanir un petit peu les les les
dissensus qui peuvent apparaître par
ailleurs ça défin aussi un profil
politique c'estàd que quand il dit je n
nous sommes le lieu des solutions je
pense que d'une certaine manière il se
distingue de son concurrent dans sa
famille politique voqué qui lui est
beaucoup beaucoup plus idéologue tandis
que là lui il est celui il est l'homme
qui peut rassembler autour de sa
pratique éventuellement de son nom des
personnes qui n'ont pas été toujours
dans le même parti ou alors qu' l'ont
été puis qui ne le sont plus autour de
solution pragmatique et concrète donc
moi je pense que pour rebondir sur la
question de tout à l'heure est-ce que il
se sert de son mandat oui bien sûr qu'il
s'en
sert oui non mais je veux dire c'est pas
oui surtout c'est que ce n'est pas de
l'instrument
c'est que je pense que ça a à voir avec
la place où il se trouve et à cet
endroitl il est en contact avec ceux qui
sont sur le terrain et qui ont fonction
justement d'essayer de faire vivre le
vivre ensemble et donc de ne pas cliver
et de rassembler et donc de ce point de
vue ça définit un profil
politique qui certainement sera
identifié dans sa famille David Lisnard
d'ailleurs l'a dit le pouvoir local est
une des solutions à tous les mots dont
nous avons parlé depuis euh depuis
depuis le le le début de cette émission
il y a il y a tous ces mots que le maire
se se reçoit toute cette violence et
cetera mais c'est aussi l'une des
solutions aujourd'hui bah oui c'est
d'autant plus vrai que la démonstration
a été brillamment faite au cours des
différentes des dernières crises qui
est-ce que qui est-ce que le l'État est
allé chercher pour pour apaiser au
moment des gilets jaunes les maires qui
est-ce qui a été en première ligne dans
la gestion de la crise sanitaire au
moment du covid les
donc voilà qui qui a été directement ne
sont pas le problème ce sont la solution
même cet été cet été au moment
de exctement on pe on peut multiplier
les les exemples le mais et donc il y a
il y a il y a
cette cet aspect des choses est
intéressant si vous voulez parce que il
y a une capacité à il y a une capacité à
faire ensemble il y a une vraie
efficacité les maires sont la solution
et à un moment il faudrait aussi que que
l'État fasse réellement confiance euh
aux élus locaux et pour l'instant oui
c'est ça ils ont fait leur preuve et il
serait temps de de de vraiment oui alors
pour il a eu beaucoup cette
décentralisation non mais encore une
fois il y a eu beaucoup de mots très
positifs en la matière plein de
promesses et cetera qui sont sur la
table depuis depuis un depuis un un
paquet de temps en fait rappelez-vous
quoi sur la
décentralisation la déconcentration des
services de l'État pour qu'il travaille
plus en
proximité le droit à la différenciation
l'expérimentation dernièrement
c'était le comment le l'autonomie pour
certaines collectivités comme la Corse
par exemple enfin il y a plein de chose
mais mais
concrètement on en reste on pour
l'instant on toujours bah dans une dans
dans la dans on peut pas dire que rien
ne se passe c'est pas vrai il y a des
choses qui avancent mais en fait il y a
plus de mots que de que d'action et que
de réalisation et et et je pense que ça
ça participe aussi au fait qu'il y a une
tension
qui ne cesse de de monter pas qu'avec
les maires avec tous les élus en fait
parce que en disant bah ça fait un
moment que vous n racontez la même chose
mais nous sur le terrain on envoie on
envoie pas les fruits ceci dit juste
pour terminer après quand même je pense
qu'il faut quand même rappeler qu'il y a
eu des époque où les tensions entre
l'Association des maères de France et et
le et le et le gouvernement ou la
présidence de la République était
beaucoup plus forte que que cette année
là c'est quand même plus voilà il y a
des problèmes euh il y a des difficultés
qui sont abordées qui sont partagées
mais euh le niveau de tension et de ou
de rivalité vous dites que c'est pas le
même que d'autres il y a eu il y a eu
des il y a eu des époques où c'était
quand même plus c'était plus compliqué
c'est c'est pas on n'est pas au beau fix
aujourd'hui mais il y a eu des époques
où c'était notoirement plus compliqué
moi il y a ce qu'on dit il y a ce qu'on
fait nous dit Stéphane oui mais moi je
pense quand même euh que les mares ont
quand même acquis des pouvoirs
substantiels qui sont pas forcément euh
tout à fait bien identifiés et en
particulier je pense que la question de
l'aménagement du territoire du
développement urbain et cetera qui sont
des des des leviers fondamentaux dans la
dynamique économique dans le vivre
ensemble dans la couture du territoire
ce sont des des endroits sur lequels les
maires ont vraiment la main et que donc
je pense qu'on peut doit on doit voir
aussi des choses qui nous apparaissent
pas si clairement mais qui sont
essentielles merci Catherine merci
Stéphane d'avoir participé à décrypter
cette séance de clôture tout de suite
David lnard qui fait discours de Clure
le président de l'association fr du
Sénat ch Françoise ch Françoise Gatel je
salue bien sûr territoires Unis plus
unis que jamais je crois que c'était
extrêmement clair tout à l'heure à
travers Carole Delga présidente de
région de France et François sauad pour
les départements Mesdames et Messieurs
les représentants d'élus
d'association d'élus nos chers
partenaires je tiens à ce titre à saluer
Sébastien Martin pour intercommunauté de
France GAV rou pour ville-de-fance
Jean-Luc moudinc pour France urbaine
Pascal Boyet pour l'association des élus
de la montagne Christophe bouillon pour
l'association des petites villes de
France et pardonnez-moi si j'en nommais
monsieur le Président de la Polynésie
française bien sûr je salue tous les
membres du bureau et je félicite chacun
pour cha inclusive de chacun de chacune
pour sa réélection avec une mention bien
sûr au premier vice-président Andr léel
qui vient de lire intégralement le texte
de notre résolution et ce qui me permet
de saluer parce que ça leur rappellera
des souvenirs les présidents d'honneur
de la MEF ici présent Jean-Paul delevois
Jacques Pélissard et françois Barouin
qui nous font l'honneur d'être avec
nous et on peut les
[Applaudissements]
applaudir ils sont irremplaçables et
j'ai dû
succéder Mesdames et Messieurs les
Présidents des associations
départementales de M ce formidable
réseau de 102 associations d'une densité
d'une intensité d'une qualité absolument
essentielle avec lequel ce réseau la la
maison mère AMF travaille étroitement
dans le respect de l'indépendance de
chacun je salue bien sûr avec
beaucoup de respect aussi de
reconnaissance de
attitude pour la confiance accordé à
nouveau l'ensemble des maires des
présidents d'intercommunalité de France
des élus municipaux ici représentés mes
très chers collègues je vous remercie du
fond du cœur de votre confiance nous
parvenons à transcender les clivages
partisans les différences géographiques
économiques sociales pour donner une
voix forte à l'Association des maires de
France et des présidents
d'intercommunalité c'est pour moi un imm
honneur que de pouvoir porter la parole
des communes de France c'est une grande
responsabilité c'est un devoir et je
m'attacherai avec les instances de
l'association de l'assumé avec
enthousiasme passion et la volonté de
faire entendre nos
préoccupations nos solutions aussi nos
réalités à nouveau merci à vous je veux
saluer mes collègues nos collègues
d'outrem et avec qui nous avons tenu une
fois de plus une très très belle journée
lundi une participation au débat très
fort pour évoquer en particulier le
désordre
foncier les problématiques de la vie
cher et pouvons être fier que la MF soit
une fois de plus et plus que jamais
d'ailleurs la voix aussi de nos autres
maères je salue également les
délégations internationales qui ont fait
le déplacement et en particulier les
importante délégation du Sénégal et de
la Côte
d'Ivoire mes chers collègues venus de
toute la
France Merci d'être
ici merci à ceux qui viennent d'ailleurs
nous avions l'année dernière organiser
un moment fort pour l'Ukraine et je veux
saluer à nouveau une délégation de la
ville d'ichnia qui est ici présente et
le dire que nous n'oublions pas la
situation en Ukraine un an après
l'agression russe se poursuit
et nous sommes constants dans notre
soutien humanitaire aux populations
ukrainienne je remercie enfin Madame
l'ambassadrice d'Arménie pour son
message fort clair porté tout à
l'heure après celui puissant de michaell
Patti mesdames Messieurs mes chers
collègues mes chers
amis nous accueillons avec plaisir
madame la Première ministre bienvenue
Bienvenue par parmi les maires et les
présidents d'intercommunalité de France
madame la Première ministre vous avez
raison d'être
là vous avez raison d'être là car la
France dans toute sa diversité est ici
rassemblée unie honoré de vous
accueillir respectueuse des institutions
de la
République vous avez raison d'être là
parce que vous êtes ici en présence de
la France des centrebourgs des villages
des villes des villes moyen
comme des métropoles c'est la France de
nos montagnes de nos campagnes de nos
quartiers de notre littoral de nos
outrmers et que cette France est
belle c'est la France aussi du bon sens
du bon sens des 35000 conseils
municipaux et de tous ceux qui les font
vivre du bon sens tout simplement de
l'action de la nécessité d'agir c'est la
France réelle c'est la France de la vie
ici réunie porte de
versaill c'est la France de la vie et de
la réalité car les communes viennent du
fond de notre histoire elles sont
enracinées quel joli terme pour citer la
grande philosophe Simone veille elles
sont la concrétisation humaine de notre
géographie elles sont le creusé de notre
culture de nos racines communes
individuelles et collectives nos
communes incarnent à la fois la
transmission et la modernité le bon sens
et la performance
elle représente dans une société hélas
trop fragmentée peut-être la dernière
institution solide comme nous l'avons
démontré à chaque crise et ce fut le cas
entre autres lors du covid une
institution solide qui produit des
services de proximité et qui produit
quelque chose de rare d'important de
nécessaire qui est le sentiment
d'appartenance nos communes sont
vivantes nos communes sont
modernes ce ne sont pas des archaïsmes
ceux qui nous traitent de ringard et
d'archaïque il y a quelques années c'est
eux qui sont ringard et archaïqu c'est
les technonformistes c'est ceux qui
centralisent c'est ceux qui pensent que
une action n'est pertinente neutre et
respectueuse de l'esprit républiquain
que lorsqu'elle est
descendante les communes sont la France
qui crée la France qui innove la France
qui ne demande qu'à pouvoir travailler
la France qui accueille chacun sans
distinction qui recoule tissu social au
quotidien dans nos centres communaux
d'action sociale et si nous sommes si
nombreux
réunis c'est parce que nous connaissons
l'importance de ce moment pour évoquer
ensemble les préoccupations majeures du
pays dès l'an dernier nous vous
alertions sur notre volonté de pouvoir
agir c'était le thème du Congrès l'année
dernière au combien je crois important
et et que nous nous prolongons
aujourd'hui que nous
accentuons nous évoquions déjà encore et
toujours les entraves fiscales juridique
administrative croissante qui porte
atteinte à la
démocratie la résolution qui vient
d'être lu en est l'expression
détaillée certains parfois disent que
nous voyons que le négatif c'est pas
vrai tous les jours nous montrons notre
capacité d'innovation face au défis
écologi aux exigences économiques et
sociales aux difficultés
démographiques
à l'étourdissant en jeu
numérique mais n notre devoir est
d'exprimer d'exprimer ce qui nous
empêche de
travailler d'exprimer aussi nos craintes
nos constats et nous alertions dès
l'année dernière face à la hausse des
violences et
malheureusement l'année écoulé nous a
donné raison de sources du ministère de
l'intérieur après avoir augmenté de 32 %
en un an entre 2022 et 2021 les
agressions contre les élus sont à
nouveau en
hausse au moins 15 % de plus encore
cette année et je ne vais pas citer la
liste de tous nos confrères collègues
agressés dénigré
injurier mais permettez-moi d'évoquer
bien sûr le maire de Saint-Brévin Lespin
qui a vu son domicile incendier en
pleine nuit en mars dernier Yannick morz
des missionnaires depuis et le maire de
la î rose Vincent jambrin dans le Val de
Marne j'en reviens pas là-dessus mais
avec cette tentative d'assassinat sur sa
famille ce véhicule bélier qui a foncé à
l'intérieur de de son domicile et et la
poursuite de sa femme et de ses enfants
c'est un palier supplémentaire franchi
dans ses violences nos familles sont
désormais de plus en plus victimes de
ces agissements et nous on n'est pas là
pour se plaindre pour gémir on est là
pour garder la tête haute et vouloir
tout simplement assumer nos mandats dans
un contexte
difficile les démissions de M atteignent
des records et je crois que c'est quand
même tout à l'honneur de la MF que
d'avoir su et cela avait commencé avec
François avec françois Barouin d'avoir
su faire comprendre cette réalité d'en
avoir fait finalement un objet à
l'agenda politique et
médiatique deux fois plus de démission
de MRE sur la décennie en cours que sur
la décennie précédente 100 %
d'augmentation avec une moyenne de
démission de 40 mèes par mois depuis
2020 c'est une
réalité avec une autre réalité celle que
révèlent nos enquêtes d'opinion et les
études que nous faisons avec le cvipof
le centre de recher charge de sciences
fa plus d'un mer sur deux envisage de ne
pas se représenter en 2026 certains
m'ont fait part ici de leur décision
d'ailleurs je veux d'ailleurs à ce titre
saluer le travail que nous menons avec
les
sénateurs et qui ont adopté une
proposition de loi d'ailleurs je crois à
l'unanimité sur la sécurité des élus
locaux et la protection des maires nous
souhaitons que ce texte soit voté en ces
term à l'Assemblée nationale notamment
au regarde la protection fonctionnelle
qui doit être automatique qui doit pas
être voté et qui doit être prise en
charge comme les dépositaires de
l'autorité publique que nous sommes et
au-delà des évolutions pénales et nous y
travaillons aussi avec Dominique fort
que je salue
euh le droit est une chose mais son
application en est une autre et à ce
titre nous
souhaitons que les moyens comme pour
toutes les victimes et pas simplement
les maires car nous ne voulons pas de
privilège que que tous les moyens soient
donnés pour que les parquettiers
puissent bosser que les parquets
puissent avoir les moyens de poursuivre
d'instruire et qu'on cesse d'avoir trop
de procédures sauf lorsqu'elles sont
médiatisées qui trop souvent se
traduisent et alors que les éléments
d'identification des auteurs sont réels
en classement sans
suite nous souhaitons aussi comme toutes
les victimes pouvoir être tenu informé
des évolutions des enquêtes je crois que
c'est un sujet majeur dans le respect
bien sûr du secret de l'instruction mais
toutes les victimes le le disent et et
les maires aussi d'être informé car le
pire est de ne pas avoir de suite et de
ne pas être tenu informé s'attaquer à un
élu parce qu'il est élu traduit ce que
nous constatons c'est une attaque sur la
République tout simplement et si nous
avons choisi mes chers collègues comme
thème de notre 105e congrès commune
attaquée République menacée c'est pour
pour pousser non seulement un cri
d'alarme mais c'est aussi pour appeler à
la
mobilisation nous sommes un tournant
dangereux de notre démocratie je crois
que chacun le ressent très bien les
violences sont une des expressions de la
déliquessence civique et au-delà de la
crise de la démocratie que nous
affrontons oui nous ressentons
profondément que notre démocratie est
attaquée parce que nos communes sont
attaquées lorsque 168 écoles sont
incendiées et attaqué lors des émeutes
urbaines jamais dans l'histoire du pays
une école n'avait été dégradée ni sous
la révolution ni en 1830 ni en 1848 ni
en 1870 ni au moment des mouvements
violents fascistes des années 30 alors
oui notre République est menacée notre
République française est menacée parce
qu'elle est pas vide notre République
c'est celle du substrat de notre
nation notre République est menacée
aussi quand le mérite est menacé quand
la laïcité est attaquée quand l'ordre
est bafoué
quand la justice est
dénigrée notre République est attaquée
parce que notre capacité à transcender
les identités individuelles est
menacée parce que en cela
l'universalisme républicain qui est un
trésor qui ne juge pas l'autre sur ce
qu'il est mais sur ce qu'il fait bref
qui condamne toute forme de racisme est
attaqué parce que la liberté valeur
impérissable de l'histoire disait le
grand Camu est menacé or la liberté d'un
peuple a un nom c'est la démocratie
notre démocratie est en danger quand des
empires extérieurs illibéraux voire
dictatoriaux nous en avons évoqué tout à
l'heure se reconstittu et exprime des
visés expansionnistes Ukraine Afrique
subsaharienne Arménie notre démocratie
est en danger quant à l'intérieur du
pays des forces obscurantistes s'y
développent
l'islamisme radical le djihadisme qui
tue et qui veut
soumettre l'hommage à Samuel paatti et
Dominique Bernard étaient tout à l'heure
d'une grande puissance et nous a rappelé
à notre devoir d'affronter ses réalités
de façon active et combattante sans
aucune mièvrerie sans aucune
niaiserie République menacée quand le
racisme s'y exprime République
démocratie France attaquée quand
l'antisémitisme me s'y déploie parfois
sans
complexe
antisémitisme dont les actes ont été
quatre fois supérieurs depuis le 7
octobre à ce qu'ils ont été sur toute
une année en
2022 antisémitisme qui s'exprime depuis
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas du 7
octobre et je veux ici dans mon propos
exprimer une pensée pour nos
compatriotes nos compatriotes qui
méritent un hommage national
qui ont été assassinés en Israël le 7
octobre pour les h otages français
détenus par le Hamas vous me permettrez
d'adresser un salut à Michal et
respectueux à VE omman ici présente dans
la famille déjà profondément éprouvée
lors de la choie a été particulièrement
affectée par ces événements puisque elle
a perdu deux membres de sa famille
assassiné et quatre sont aujourd'hui
détenus en
[Applaudissements]
otage le 12
novembre à l'appel du président du Sénat
et de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale les maires de France ont su se
réunir se rassembler et marquer là aussi
au-delà de tout clivage partisan et
c'est ce qui fait la grandeur de de
notre association réunie comme jamais
notre volonté de dire que nous
n'accepterons pas
l'antisémitisme je veux saluer la
présence parmi nous du président du CRIF
et de sa délégation saluer tous ceux qui
ont manifesté la République française
n'existe pas si elle accepte en son sein
tout relativisme historique tout
négationnisme tout
antisémitisme
notre République
française notre République française est
attaqué et menacé par la faiblesse
morale du pas de vague la lâcheté de
ceux qui ne savent pas qualifier les
morts qui ne parviennent pas à condamner
le terrorisme islamiste par l'inertie de
l'esprit
municois par la naïveté de l'irénisme
qui a produit tant de dégâts dans
l'histoire du monde et parfois par
complicité
idéologique notre République française
est menacée si elle ne se réarme pas
moralement et sur le plan régalien le
déditement régalien et plus largement
l'impuissance
publique crée la voix ouvre la voix à
toute les aventures extrémistes
oui notre démocratie est en crise son
modèle d'efficacité est remise en cause
et notre devoir est de démontrer que la
démocratie est efficace et capable
d'agir
efficacité de l'exécution qui conduit 40
% des Français à se déclarer favorable à
un régime
autoritaire face à cela nous avons tous
un devoir un ardent devoir et nous maire
de France et président
d'intercommunalité je le répète ne
baissons et de baisserons ni les yeux ni
les bras par nos alertes par nos
constats par nos proposition par notre
détermination par nos actions et par les
positions de la MF
l'AMF l'association des MRES de France
est la voix de ceux qui connaissent les
réalités profondes du pays car laamf
n'est ni un syndicat ni une officine
partisane même si certains voudraient
nous qualifier ainsi pour ne pas
répondre à nos arguments
étayés les maires sont des praticiens du
quotidien et vous êtes madame la
Première ministre devant une AMF plus
forte et plus représentative que jamais
de la quasittalité des intercommunalités
des communes française avec un taux
d'adhésion jamais atteint avec ces 102
associations départementales que
j'aiévoqué tout à l'heure qui effectue
un travail remarquable et et que je
tiens à saluer et que nous soutiendrons
je renouvelle mes remerciements nos
remerciements au nom du bureau au nom
d'André léniel de moi-même de tous ceux
qui nous accompagnent pour cette
unanimité
exprimée depuis 2 ans je me suis employé
à ce que nous parvenions au sein de nos
instances à une une approche unanime
argumentée de toutes les prises de
position qui échappe à toute
considération partisane ou personnelle
et j'y veillerai à l'avenir avec la même
exigence je veux aussi féliciter tout le
travail mené tout au long de l'année par
l'équipe de l'association nous ne sommes
qu'une association nous ne sommes ni un
législatif ni un exécutif équipe sous
l'autorité de son directeur général Éric
Verlac que je remercie et salue et puis
me permettez-moi de saluer euh le
travail qui a été mené pour réussir ce
congrès et ce salon nous venons de vivre
une édition record par le nombre de
thématiques abordé 39 par le nombre
d'intervenants de 130 le nombre
d'accrédités au salon plus presque plus
25 % le nombre record d'élus de Mair
inscrits on a passé la barre des 11000
au Congrès la résolution que le nouveau
bureau a adopté à l'unanimité ce matin
et que vient de lire mot à mot le
premier vi-président André léiel marque
notre état d'esprit c'est la fidèle
traduction de nos travaux commun de nos
positions communes de nos propositions
communes notre association est plus que
jamais la voix des maires elle est utile
au maires par son travail quotidien et
par ses prises de position
oui madame la Première ministre vous
avez eu raison d'être là car c'est aussi
pour moi l'occasion de vous dire que
nous avons réussi à travailler ensemble
depuis un an avec des avancées je pense
à la réintégration des dépenses
d'aménagement des terrains dans le
FCTVA je pense à la revalor tion du
statut des secrétaires de mairie
largement inspiré par nos
propositions je pense à la prise en
compte de la situation des communes
nouvelles avec cet engagement que vous
avez pris et vous me l'avez confirmé
avant le congrès que la DGF et les
dotations des communes nouvelles ne
seront pas inférieures à la somme des
anciennes dotations des communes qui les
constituent je pense aux travaux que
nous menons sur le statut de l'élu et
sur les conditions d'exercice du mandat
avec Dominique fort dont nous attendons
la concrétisation et je veux salu aussi
le travail de Muriel Fab notre
secrétaire général particulièrement
pertinent je pense à nos actions pour
obtenir des dispositif d'accompagnement
à la hausse exponentielle des prix de
l'énergie alors bien sûr beaucoup
d'écueil subsistent voire émergent et
puis bien sûr nous contestons le
mouvement profond de recentralisation
qui hélas accompagne des discours sur la
décentralisation pour revenir sur la
facteur énergétique je me permets vous
alerter sur la situation
castropique de commune et
d'intercommunalité dans quelques
semaines lorsque les dispositifs
d'accompagnement ne seront plus en place
nous sommes nous allons vers de graves
difficultés qu'il convient regarder en
face et je crois que nous aurons et vous
aurit à trouver les dispositifs
d'accompagnement pour accompagner nos
communes je pas non plus sur
lean cette énormité bureaucratique comme
d'autres machins qu'on nous impose
régulièrement je ne reviens pas sur la
fameuse consigne
plastique qui peut mettre à mal la
filière du tri et qui au gré des
annonces en disant non c'est bon c'est
fini puis ça revient comme une espèce de
Highlander
technocratique que nous devons
affronter François Vigier c'est de quoi
je parle alors je ne veux pas vous
infliger à nouveau la litanie nos
difficultés et parfois nos exaspérations
de tout ce que évoque à chaque fois pour
refaire la liste
des schémas que nous devons respecter et
cetera alors c'est pourquoi je ne vous
parlerai pas de la crise du logement qui
est devant nous qui est une bombe à
retardement humaine
sociale les génies ont pensé que
lorsqu'on rendait le foncier
inaccessible en créant la
rareté on faciliterait l'accès en
premier première année d'économie on
apprend que ce qui est rare et cher
manifestement certains ont dû faire trop
d'études pour ne pas comprendre ce
raisonnement de
base la loi climat et résilience c'est
une bombe à fragmentation
bureaucratique avec ses acronymes ou ces
sigles en trois lettres qui portent
malheur
zan
DPE ZFE à chaque fois ça se termine mal
et à chaque fois il faut refaire une loi
pour démenteler la
loi je ne vous parlerai pas madame la
Première ministre des difficultés
d'assurance auxquell nous devons faire
face depuis les émeutes du mois de juin
et
depuis l'accélération des catastrophes
naturelles tout à l'heure encore merde
montarg pass sa franchise passe de 7500
€ à 2 million d'euros il y a comm un
léger gap quand on arrive encore à être
assuré
d'ailleurs je remercie le président
Larcher de l'annonce d'instituer une
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur les
assurances je ne parlerai pas des
difficultés de sécurité que nous
affrontons de la nécessité de faire en
sorte que les polices municipales ne
soient pas les supplétives de l'État
mais reste sous l'autorité des maires
tout en augmentant leur
pouvoir je ne vais pas vous reparler de
fiscalité locale puisque celle-ci est
réduite comme pot de
chagrin simplement vous dire que
il serait convenable lorsque nous
discutons avec l'exécutif d'une mise à
plat du système financier tel que
d'ailleurs cela a été évoqué par le
Président de la République hier et que
nous disons que il faudrait quand même
réfléchir à un impôt universel
résidentiel on ne soit pas tout de suite
dénigré de façon démagogique y compris
au sein du gouvernement sur les ondes en
disant le contraire de ce qu'on nous dit
en privé ah là là la MF veut créer un
impôt de plus non non non non pas du
tout il y a trop d'impôt il y a trop de
fiscalité il y a trop de prélèvement
obligatoire en France mais ce que l'on
constate c'est que plus on nous a
supprimé d'impôts locaux plus à la fin
il y a eu de prélèvement obligatoire en
France et que nous
trouvons
profondément profondément injuste que
l'exécutif fasse reposer l'effort fiscal
local que sur les
propriétaires pas vous parler madame
Prem ministre des injonctions
contradictoires auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés qui nous enjoignent de
construire x logements sociaux à l'avant
à la fin de l'année mais de ne pas
artificialiser les
sols en même temps qui en
outrem de demande aussi de mener du
développement mais font que les CDP NAF
pour une raison que nous ignorons
toujours et produisent un avis conforme
alors que dans l'Hexagone c'est un avis
simple une demande récurrente et
légitime des outremè qui se sentent
déconsidéré à travers cette mesure je ne
parlerai pas des inerties que nous
affrontons sur des solutions pourtant
évidentes notamment face au défis
écologique que nous devons relever et
j'en profite je profite de la la
présence de Christophe Béchu que je
salue pour et qu'on peut applaudir il a
son fan
club il est bravo c'est bien organisé
monsieur Béchu je vous félicite
alors puisque c'est bien
organisé sur la réutilisation des EAU
usées nous avons nous étions les
premiers il y a 10 ans à lancer des
projets en Europe nous sommes les
derniers les derniers de l'Europe
désormais et je voulais dire que il y a
eu des avancées pour nous permettre
d'utiliser les e usé pour les laver les
voiries mais que nous attendons toujours
l'autorisation de pouvoir arroser nos
espaces verts avec les e usé traités qui
répondent à toutes les normes
d'innocquuité et sanitaire et que ça
illustre bien cet état qui centralise
parce que après tout il suffirait que
l'État contrôle à postérior qu'on
respecte les normes sans que l'on passe
par des autorisations préalables et
c'est ce que j'ai constaté depuis 20 ans
c'est que nous sommes passés d'un régime
d' d'un régime de liberté à un régime
d'autorisation alors don madame la
Première ministre je ne vais pas vous
faire la litanie de toutes nos
difficultés il ne tient après tout qu'à
l'exécutif et au Parlement d'y remédier
il est temps de mettre tout simplement
de remettre de la démocratie là où il y
a bureaucratie de la remplacer par la
démocratie locale et c'est comme cela
que l'on retrouvera du sens et de la
performance il est temps de faire
confiance au ma et de nous donner les
moyens d'agir pour faire face à nos
défis à nos difficultés nous pouvons
nous devons être fort dans ce 21e siècle
si exigeant imaginez madame la Première
ministre Chab tout ce que nous pourrions
faire si l'état nous FA enfin confiance
nous proposons que la France sorte de
cette matrice
recentralisatrice ce que nous vous
proposons et ce que je vous propose ici
au nom des maires de France c'est doser
la liberté doser la liberté non
seulement pour les collectivités
territoriales mais aussi pour l'État et
pour la
société c'est pour ça que vous avez eu
raison nous allons vous proposer de vous
libérer de la surcharge
bureaucratique nous vous proposons Mame
la première
ministre un acte fort de
libération parce que notre liberté sera
la liberté de l'État et des
administrations centrales délester des
compétences qu'elle ne parviennent pas à
exercer
correctement transférer comme la MF le
demande depuis des années le pouvoir
réglementaire aux collectivités locales
ça sera la meilleure des réforme de
décentralisation que nous pouvons mener
la plus simple la plus efficace et ainsi
vous libérerez
des milliers de fonctionnaires d'État
que vous pourrez remettre sur le terrain
dans nos préfectures dans nos
sous-préfectures sous l'autorité des
préfets des
sous-préfets non
plus pour nous délivrer des opération
des autorisations à priori mais nous
pour nous contrôler à postériori et
sanctionner ceux d'entre nous qui
pourrai sortir des clous libérez les
agents de
l'adreal
pourquoi pas transférer une partie des
compétences au collectivités au
département et transférer les autres
sous l'autorité directe des
préfets prenons acte de l'échec de
l'agentialisation et de la
régionalisation des services de l'État
et parallèlement à la décentralisation
menons cet acte de déconcentration
efficace des services de l'État qui nous
permettra d'être plus efficace auprès
des usagers et de mieux défendre les
contribuables la confiance envers les
élus locaux cœur de la France garant de
l'unité nationale et bâtisseurs de la
cohésion sociale doit être retrouvé en
vous libérant vous allez libérer l'État
et vous allez libérer la société pour
améliorer la performance pour améliorer
l'efficacité donc le service rendu au
public et pour soulager les
contribuables libérons-nous de toutes
ces autorisations préalables de ces
schémas directeurs de ce léviatant
bureaucratique qui font perdre du temps
qui font perdre de l'argent qui font
perdre les nerfs libérons-nous de ce qui
nous empêche d'agir il faut que la loi
soit plus sobre plus concentré sur des
principes généraux et je sais que vous
partagez cette approche madame la
Première ministre plus concentré sur les
principes généraux des principes d'ordre
public et que le pouvoir règlementaire
sauf sur le régalien évidemment soit
transféré aux collectivités
territoriales nous ne demandons pas un
droit à la
dérogation nous voulons simplement un
vrai pouvoir d'action et de
décision nous ne demandons pas de
pouvoir déroger à la loi nous voulons
simplement des lois
applicables libérons-nous des appels à
projets de cette république des SERFA
des appels à manifestation d'intérêt qui
amplifi la fracture territoriale au
détriment de la ruralité au détriment
des collectivités qui n'ont pas
d'ingénerie limérons-nous de ces termes
Barbar de cette malédiction que
j'évoquéis tout à l'heure des acrodibles
et des sigles
permettez au maires de disposer d'un
pouvoir décisionnel sur tout ce qui
concerne leur commune service
hospitaliers classe d'école logement
gestion de l'eau pratiquons la
subsidiarité libérons-nous des
obligations de transfert obligatoire de
compéten aux intercommunalités qui ne
pourront jamais être pertinentes sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
laissez-nous retrouver de l'autonomie
fiscale plutôt que de concentrer les
forces fiscales sur les seuls
propriétaires et de nous mettre sous
dépendance de dotation et chaque année
les maires alors il faut que la dotation
calcule le bout de grass ça suit pas
l'inflation et cetera si on pouvait
s'épargner tout cela si on pouvait selon
un pacte social local le contrat social
local décider du niveau de fiscalité
avec les habitants qui nous jugeront qui
nous évalueront qui nous sanctionneront
nous
récompenseront faisons confiance à la
liberté donc à la responsabilité
individuelle alors comme toujours la MF
sera présente dans tous ces débats fera
ces proposition à
travers notre comité législatif local
que nous avons mis en place il y a de an
et je salue notamment les travaux de
kigoffroid j'en ai fait part à Eric vert
à qui je crois que après ces
déclarations d'hier nous pour qui j'ai
beaucoup de respect mais on va le
convaincre assez rapidement qu'il y a
vraiment une recentralisation financière
c'est qu'on remplace un impôt local par
une dotation nationale si c'est pas une
recentralisation financière c'est que
vraiment il y a un souci de
compréhension nous vous proposons madame
la Première ministre et et c'est l'acte
fort de ce jour de libérer l'action de
libérer action publique et ainsi de
régénérer l'action communale et ainsi de
défendre la République française
régénérer la démocratie communale par la
libre administration la décentralisation
n'est pas un simple aménagement
technique de l'administration qui
transformerait les communes en
opérateurs de service de l'État en
sous-traitant de l'État nous ne sommes
pas les sous-traitants de
l'État
pourtant ce dernier aujourd'hui parce
que c'est la règle ne nous confie des
compétences que dans un cadre normatif
contraint
la décentralisation c'est quoi la vraie
décentralisation pour reprendre une
expression du président de la République
c'est la démocratisation de l'action
publique dont les élus peuvent
déterminer la nature et contrôler
l'affectation des
ressources le cadre communal où ces
politiqu sont les plus facilement
perceptibles pour le citoyen et le
terrain le plus propice à une telle
ambition la qualité des politiques
publiques décentralisé il fait l'objet
d'un contrôle politique par les
électeurs qui se prononce sur un projet
un bilan qui peuvent en apprécier le
bien fondé en cela la décentralisation
représente le Paris de l'efficacité
démocratique plutôt que bureaucratique
devant cette situation le nouveau
concept a été promu les technocrates ont
réussi à faire d'un principe de base de
la vie la différence un objet
technocratique ça s'appelle la
différenciation alors nous on se jette
dessus au départ ça a l'air bien ça la
différenciation ça peut peut-être nous
permettre de de prendre des décisions or
je crois que les mots ont toujours un
sens plutôt que d'accorder des libertés
on souhaite que celui-ci soit donné au
collectivité le droit de
déroger après avoir complexifié les
normes générales on souhaite maintenant
multiplier les régimes
singuliers les communes ne veulent pas
déroger elles aspirent à agir librement
dans le cadre de la loi
elles ne demandent pas un régime
singulier mais des règles claires et
générales fondamentalement attaché à la
République les maires de France sont
fidèles à l'unité de la loi héritée de
1789 en tant que bastion de l'unité
nationale les communes s'inquiète des
surenchères identitaires et politiques
que la notion de différenciation
pourrait
encourager attentive à l'idéal d'une
République
décentralisée inscrite dans la
Constitution elles appellent plutôt à
retrouver la voie des libertés locales
en replaçant le citoyen au centre des
réformes futures il convient aujourd'hui
de faire de la démocratie communale
l'objectif la boussole des futures
réformes au-delà même de celle de
décentralisation c'est la libre
administration autre principe
constitutionnelarticle 72 qui doit être
l'objet de toutes les
attentions libre administration ces
conditions d'exercice doivent être
déterminé et assuré si elle est garantie
donc par la Constitution elle est
souvent mal protégée et elle est encore
plus souvent
bafouée elle doit être réaffirmée
et on a la chance d'avoir le président
du Conseil constitutionnel autour de
trois axes un pouvoir normatif effectif
une autonomie fiscale une liberté de
coopération laamf madame la Première
ministre sera positive constructive mais
aussi
intransigente la décentralisation ne
doit pas être dérogatoire
elle devrait être la règle de notre
République ce que nous vous proposons
c'est de faire le choix audacieux
novateur tellement évident et prometteur
de la subsidiarité c'est-à-dire de la
responsabilité locale la subsidiarité
c'est la philosophie de la liberté car
il n'y a pas de subsidiarité sans
liberté et c'est donc la philosophie de
la dignité car il n'y a pas de dignité
sans liberté et c'est donc la
philosophie du courage car s'il n'y a
pas de dignité sans liberté il n'y a pas
de liberté sans courage la subsidiarité
procède d'une défense morale qui fait du
respect de de la dignité de la
responsabilité des personnes qui la
composent la finalité de toute société
la liberté n'a pas à se justifier c'est
la restriction de liberté qui doit être
justifiée or tout a été inversé comme la
charge de la preuve dans l'exercice
quotidiion de nos mission dans beaucoup
de cas les communes ne sont pas le
dernier mais le premier kilomètre de
l'action publique cette expression de
dernier kilomètres j'en parlis avec
Françoise mais pas dans tous les cas
mais dans beaucoup de cas le nous sommes
pas le dernier kilomètre nous sommes le
premier kilomètre et pensez que nous
sommes le dernier kilomètre c'est une
vision très centralisée par définition
de l'action publique alors il ne reste
plus qu'à avoir l'audace l'audace de la
liberté l'audace de la responsabilité
l'audace de la confiance et la confiance
doit se tradire dans les actes tout à
l'heure madame l'ambassadeur d'Arménie
cité tokeville cette célèbre citation
c'est dans la commune que réside la
force des peuples libres Tov disait
aussi plus loin dans la démocratie en
Amérique la phrase suivante et nous
évoquions nous rendions hommage aux
enseignants tout à l'heure et je fais le
lien et ma boucle sera bouclée entre
l'école et la commune les institutions
communales sont à la liberté ce que les
écoles primaires sont à la science elles
la mettent à la liberté à la portter du
peuple elles lui en font goûter l'usage
paisible et l'habitue à s'en servir sans
institution communale une nation peut se
donner un gouvernement libre mais elle
n'a pas l'esprit de la liberté c'est cet
esprit de la liberté c'est cet esprit de
la République c'est cet esprit de la
République française c'est cet esprit de
la France que nous vous proposons de
faire vivre dans les mois qui viennent
vive la France vive la république et
vive les communes de
[Applaudissements]
France
on a été
aimable voilà David lissnard ovationné à
l'occasion de ce discours de clôture de
ce 105e congrès de l'Association des
maires de France vous avez vu hein les
maires rassemblés qui l'ont applaudi et
maintenant va lui succéder la première
ministre ellisabeth born cher Laurent
Fabius éoute Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires monsieur le président de
l'Association des maires de France cher
David
lissenard mesdames et messieurs les
membres du bureau et du comité
directeurs Mesdames et Messieurs les
maires Mesdames et Messieurs les élus
mesdames et
messieurs au cœur de notre pacte
républicain au cœur de notre cohésion
nationale se trouvent les
commune toutes et tous vous représentez
une parcelle de notre nation de son
histoire de ses aspirations et de ses
défis des plus petits villages aux plus
grandes villes de nos côtes à nos
montagnes de nos ruralités à nos
banlieux chacune et chacun vous incarnez
une facette de notre pays et réunis
ensemble aujourd'hui vous le formez dans
son
entier Mesdames et Messieurs les maires
vous êtes celles et ceux qui changent
les
quotidiens ceux dont les projets voient
le jour et améliorent la vie de nos
concitoyens ceux qui innovent osent et
expérimentent vous connaissez notre pays
et ses habitants vous présentez ses
inquiétudes vous savez ses doutes et ses
attentes vous êtes les artisans de
l'intérêt
général vous êtes en première ligne
toujours au côté des Françaises et des
Français parant calme comme dans les
crises vous l'avez montré encore une
fois lors des émeutes de cet été dans
les 500 communes touchées par les
violences les maires ont été des repères
pour rappeler le cap de la République
ils ont été déterminants pour pour aider
à ramener l'ordre
républicain vous êtes indispensable pour
penser l'avenir et éviter que de telles
violences ne se
reproduis vous êtes sans cesse en
première ligne et j'ai pu encore le
mesurer ces dernières semaines en me
rendant auprès des maires de mon
département du Calvados après la tempête
kirane puis auprès des maires du pas
decalis touché par des Cruses
exceptionnelles face aux intempéries de
ces derniers jours les maires les élus
locaux les employés municipaux ont fait
pr d'un grand sang frroid et d'un
courage
remarquable alors qu'ils faisaient
eux-mêmes partie des victimes ils ont
accompagné nos concitoyens aider les
secours trouver des solutions pour
reloger les familles ou accueillir les
enfants dont les écoles étaient fermé je
veux rendre hommage ici avec vous toutes
et tous aux Mair et aux élus des
territoires touchés par les tempêtes
Kiran et Domingos ainsi que par les
inondations dans le pas
decalis
[Applaudissements]
et comme le président de la République
l'a affirmé comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire face à l'urgence
comme dans la reconstruction l'état
répondra présent Mesdames et Messieurs
les maires c'est bien cela le cœur de
mon message aujourd'hui l'État répondra
présent il y a un an ici même j'ai
présenté devant vous une méthode qui
repose sur trois piliers l'écoute le
dialogue et la
coconstruction cette méthode se fonde
aussi sur un principe la confiance une
confiance qui ne se décrète pas mais qui
se gagne et se construit acte après
acte une confiance à laquelle je tiens
plus que tout car je crois que je crois
que pour toutes nos décisions la parole
des Maes doit être
entendu cette année ensemble nous avons
avancé sur plusieurs défis
majeurs je pense à la protection des
élus vous en avez parlé monsieur le
Président
lisenard vous m'en parlez aussi Mesdames
et Messieurs les maires lors de nos
rencontres être maire être élu c'est
être en première ligne face à la
brutalisation de la
société les menaces les injures sur les
réseaux sociaux les agressions trop
d'entre vous me disent qu'elles sont
devenu leur
quotidien vous le dites quand nos
communes sont attaquées nous ne
banaliserons rien nous ne pouvons pas
nous habituer nous refusons de nous
résigner si vous n'êtes pas en sécurité
la République n'est pas en
sécurité en mai dernier après l'attaque
inacceptable dont il avait fait l'objet
j'avais reçu le maire de Saint-Brévin et
les représent des associations d'élus
vous m'aviez fait part cher David lnard
de plusieurs propositions à votre écoute
avec vous avec les ministres Gérald
armanin Éric Dupont Moretti Christophe
Béchu et Dominique fort nous avons
construit un plan national de lutte
contre les violences faites aux élus son
principe est simple un meilleur
accompagnement et une fermeté implacable
contre les
auteurs cette fermeté ne se fa pas de
mots ce sont des actes ceux qui s'en
prennent à vous encourront désormais les
mêmes peines que ceux qui agressent nos
forces de l'ordre mais je sais que le
compte n'y est pas encore je sais qu'il
y a encore trop d'affaires qui
n'aboutissent pas nous devons faire plus
et nous y travaillerons avec vous et
avec les parlementaires engagés sur ce
[Applaudissements]
sujet ensemble cette année nous avons
également agi autour d'un défi majeur la
transition
écologique vous êtes les premiers
témoins du dérèglement climatique et de
ses conséquences sur vos communes vous
avez à votre disposition beaucoup des
leviers essentiels pour mener les
changements
nécessaires la réalité est simple sans
les territoires il n'y aura pas de
transition écologique nous avons besoin
de vous besoin de vos initiatives besoin
de vos idées gestion de l'eau déchets
mobilité développement du bio dans les
cantines rénovation des écoles l'État
est avec vous pour relever ses défis
c'est le sens de la pérenisation du fond
vert à hauteur de 2,5 milliards d'euros
par an pour soutenir vos projets pour
ancrer nos actions sur le terrain au
plus près des réalité locale nous
partirons évidemment de vos initiatives
c'est notamment le sens des COP
territoriales lancé par Christophe
Béchu et puisque j'évoque la transition
écologique on ne doit pas la mener en
empêchant le développement et
l'aménagement de vos
territoires j'en suis bien consciente
l'objectif de zéro artificialisation
nette en 2050 est un sujet difficile qui
provoque des inquiétudes voire des
tensions je sais aussi que tous ensemble
nous nous nous partageons la nécessité
d'assurer la qualité des sols de nous
protéger contre les inondations de
sauvegarder la biodiversité et de
préserver nos
paysages la nécessité aussi de dynamiser
nos
centreesbourg l'année dernière devant
vous j'avais pris des engagements pour
vous donner plus de souplesse et
garantir le développement des
territoires ruraux grâce au travail mené
avec vous et avec les par parlementaire
chacun de ces engagements a été tenu et
une loi a été adoptée cet été à la quasi
unanimité et je veux saluer le travail
de concertation mené par Christophe
Béchu il faut maintenant que cette loi
d'assouplissement se mette en œuvre dans
chaque territoire et vous offre un cadre
qui tienne mieux compte de vos
spécificités dans les prochains jours
les textes d'application seront publiées
et les préfets vous présenteront cette
nouvelle manière de mettre en œuvre
objectifs de sobriété
foncière toutefois j'en ai bien
conscience tout n'est pas réglé les Maes
ruraux le savent bien nous devons
continuer le travail sur le modèle
économique de la sobriété foncière nous
devons adapter la fiscalité aux
nouvelles exent exigences de lutte
contre
l'artificialisation j'ai bien entendu la
proposition de l'AMF nous souhaitons
avancer avec vous rapidement sur ce
sujet Mesdames et Messieurs les les
maires je vous l'ai dit notre travail
repose sur la confiance et la confiance
c'est aussi faire le choix des libertés
local monsieur le Président Lisnard
comme vous j'y suis profondément
attaché lors des rencontres de sainten
autour du président de la République un
point d'accord a émerger autour d'une
idée forte vous donnez plus de pouvoir
d'agir aujourd'hui tous les élus locaux
que je rencontre me le disent vos
projets sont entravés par des procédures
trop lourdes vous êtes freiné par des
normes nationales qui imposent trop
souvent les moyens à employer plutôt que
les objectifs à atteindre qui ignore de
ce fait les spécificités locales qui
sont parfois contradictoires entre elles
les conséquences vous les connaissez une
trop grande complexité et des délais
trop longs qui ne vous permettent pas
toujours de réaliser au cours de votre
mandat les projets que vous portez cela
crée des tensions et de la frustration
cela insyle un doute dans l'esprit de
nos concitoyens sur la capacité des
pouvoirs publics à agir un doute qui
nourrit l'abstention et pousse à se
tourner vers les
extrêmes aussi nous devons rendre
l'action publique plus simple plus
lisible et plus
efficace notre premier enjeu c'est de
permettre un dialogue renforcé et Contin
entre l'État et vous j'ai entendu la
proposition du Sénat d'instaurer des
conférences départementales de dialogue
entre les élus locaux et les préfets
l'État ne doit pas apparaître comme une
machine froide qui vous rappelle les
normes applicable l'État doit être un
facilitateur et vous aider à réussir vos
[Applaudissements]
projets parvenir vous n'attendez pas un
iè dispositif qui souscouvert de
simplification viendrait à nouveau vous
faire perdre du temps et créer de la
complexité la solution nous la
connaissons miser sur le couple maire
préfet j'ai été préfè je sais combien il
est précieux et ces dernières années
encore face aux crises nous avons vu
qu'il permet de déplacer des montagne et
d'avancer même face aux pires
difficultés je veux consolider le couple
maire préfet et renforcer l'état
déconcentré lui donner davantage de
capacités à trouver avec vous les bons
moyens pour atteindre les
objectifs en outre l'état ne peut pas
avoir plusieurs représentants dans un
département le préfet et le visage de
l'État sont représentant unique et le
garant de la cohérence de toutes ses
politiques publiques cela vaut pour les
services de l'État comme pour ses
agences
[Applaudissements]
j'ajoute que nous voulons également
avancer vers davantage de
décentralisation c'est le sens de la
mission confiée à Eric vert dont les
conclusions doivent être rendu au mois
de mai bien sûr il s'appuiera sur les
travaux réalisés les vôtres ce du Sénat
pour redonner aux élus locaux leur
pouvoir d'agir vous serez pleinement
associé
pour passer rapidement aux
actes il sera notamment chargé Eric vert
de proposer une voix pour vous donner
plus de prévisibilité pour vos moyens
c'est l'une de vos attentes fortes nous
voulons y répondre c'est grâce à ces
mesures que nous pourrons être plus
efficac c'est grâce à ces décisions que
nous pourrons vous faciliter la
vie mais si vous donnez des marges de
manœuvre supplémentaires et impératif ça
n'est pas encore suffisant vous donner
les moyens d'agir c'est aussi améliorer
les conditions d'exercice de vos mandats
et renforcer le statut de
l'élu aujourd'hui le mandat de maire est
devenu plus compliqué il vous expose à
plus de risque il vous demande plus de
temps et
d'énergie au début du mois la ministre
Dominique fort a réuni près de 400 élus
locaux lors de la Convention nationale
de la démocratie
locale cette concertation a permis
d'évoquer le fonctionnement quotidien
des collectivités et des
intercommunalités l'articulation du
mandat avec la vie personnel et
professionnel le niveau des indemnités
ou encore la formation des élus locaux
il nous appartient maintenant de
traduire ces propositions en acte en
lien avec vous et avec les
parlementaires dont plusieurs ont déposé
des propositions de loi j'ai demandé à
Dominique fort de faire aboutir ses
travaux au premier semestre
20 d'ors et déjà je vous annonce que la
dotation pour l'exercice des mandats
locaux sera augmenté de près de 15
million d'euros l'année prochaine cela
permettra notamment de mieux indemniser
les élus des petites communes
rurales j'ajoute que dans vos
[Applaudissements]
missionsoute dans
missionesour tiiden des agents
municipaux qui font vivre nos communes
et répondent aux besoins de nos
concitoyens et j'ai une pensée
particulière pour les secrétaire de
mairie cheville ouvrière de nos communes
avec le ministre Stanislas Guerini nous
avons travaillé avec vous et je me
réjouis que la proposition de loi pour
revaloriser leur fonction a été adoptée
à l'unanimité à l'Assemblée nationale
comme au Sénat c'est aussi cela le
témoignage de notre
reconnaissance
vous donner les moyens d'agir c'est
enfin et naturellement vous donner des
moyens
financier au moment d'évoquer cette
question je veux avoir une pensée pour
Pierre bretau maire de Saint-Grégoire
membre du bureau de l'AMF et
co-président de sa commission finances
qui nous a quitté le mois
[Applaudissements]
dernier il était un élu passionné et
constructif un connaisseur fin des
finances publiques locales et avec vous
je veux lui rendre
hommage Mesdames et Messieurs les maires
toutes et tous vous m'avez parlé des
contraintes qui pèsent sur vous de ce
sentiment de toujours devoir en faire
plus et de cette crainte de ne pas avoir
les moyens pour y
arriver le budget présenté par mon
gouvernement est un budget
d'augmentation claire et nette des
moyens de nos collectivités
en
2024 grâce à l'extension du fond de
compensation de la TVA grâce à la
pérennisation du fond vert grâce à des
niveaux élevés pour les dotations de
soutien à l'investissement local nous
allons accompagner vos projets à hauteur
de 12 milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire
près d'un quart de l'investissement
local l'année dernière nous avons
augmenté la DGF pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans grâce à cela la quit
totalité des communes ont vu leur DGF
rester stable ou progresser en
2023 cette année nous avons décidé de
continuer sur cette voie je pense aux
communes nouvelles qui conserveront le
bénéfice de leur montant de
DGF de plus le projet Doig de finance
pour
2024 prévoit une nouvelle hausse de la
DGF pour les communes comme vous l'avez
demandé nous irons plus loin encore pour
vous soutenir aussi je vous annonce que
j'ai décidé d'augmenter la DGF des
communes de 100 millions d'euros
supplémentaires la hausse atteindra donc
320 millions d'euros l'année prochaine
vous l'avez souhaité nous le faisons en
2024 la DGF des communes augmentera au
même rythme que
[Applaudissements]
l'inflation pour les années à venir
comme l'a annoncé le président de la
République hier nous devons refondre la
DGF au fil du temps elle est devenue de
plus en plus complexe et de plus en plus
incompréhensible pour les communes il
faut un système juste et clair c'est la
mission du Comité des finances locales
qui devra relever ce défi dont nous
mesurons tous
l'ampleur de plus comme vous l'aviez
souhaité monsieur le Président du Comité
des finances locales le gouvernement
continuera à aider les Collectiv
face au coût de l'énergie l'amortisseur
du prix de l'électricité sera maintenu
en
[Applaudissements]
2024 je voulais dire un mot également de
nos communes des
outrm beaucoup connaissent des
difficultés spécifiques qui imposent une
réponse adaptée c'est pourquoi nous
sommes à leur côté pour les accompagner
dans le cadre de contrats pluriannuel
qui permettent un appui technique et
financier de l'État enfin je connais les
fortes attentes des élus ruraux à propos
des zone de revitalisation
rurale vous le savez nous avons engagé
une réforme qui fusionne trois zonages
existants pour redynamiser et rendre
plus attractif leur
territoire je sais que certains
craignent de perdre le bénéfice de ce
dispositif alors même qu'il est
essentiel pour le bon déploiement de
nombreuses po publique en zone
rurale d'une part je vous annonce que
nous portons au Sénat une évolution de
notre projet pour faire entrer dans le
zonage 4000 communes de plus que prévu
initialement nous y parviendrons en
assouplissant le critère de revenu par
ailleurs nous prendrons mieux en compte
la situation spécifique des communes de
montagne d'autre part aucune entreprise
ne perdra les droits acquis à ses
exonéra fiscale sur toute la période
prévue initialement avec cet outil
adapté nous pourrons ensemble dessiner
des perspective de développement nouvel
pour nos territoires
ruraux Mesdames et Messieurs les maires
sur ces fondements je vous propose de
continuer à avancer ensemble dans les
mois qui viennent et je crois que parmi
les défis qui nous rassemblent se trouve
la question des services publics je suis
élu d'un territoire rural et je connais
bien vos inquiétudes sur leur présence
et leur qualité je sais ce que cela
représente pour la vitalité d'une
commune pour la vie des Françaises et
des Français c'est pourquoi j'ai fait de
l'amélioration des services publics une
des priorités de l'action de mon
gouvernement en un an nous avons déjà
montré notre capacité à agir ensemble je
pense à notre action commune et au
moyens renforcés décidés par l'État pour
réduire les délais des rendez-vous et de
délivrance des titre d'identité grâce à
notre mobilisation conjointe nous sommes
passés de 70 à 15 jours de délis pour
prendre
rendez-vous je pense à notre action pour
les zones rurales et j'ai présenté cet
été le le plan France ruralité qui place
la question des services publics en son
cœur je pense au plan quartier 2030 pour
les quartiers prioritaires de la
politique de la ville porté par la
secrétaire d'État Sabrina Agresti
roubach là encore il s'agit de renfor
l'accès et la qualité des services
publics essentiels en premier lieu
l'école je pense aussi au servicees
public de la petite enfance dont nous
avons défini ensemble les nouveaux
contours il permettra de créer 200000
places d'accueil d'ici
2030 ce résultat c'est le fruit de
plusieurs mois de travaux et d'échanges
mené par la ministre Aurore berger avec
les maires les parlementaires les
professionnels et la société civile
c'est une réponse concrète et attendue
par nos concitoyens ce sont aussi des
moyens à la hauteur puisque 6 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires seront mobilisés
pour la petite enfance par la Caisse
nationale des allocations familiales
mais je sais que certains défis
perdurent la santé d'abord c'est une
préoccupation majeure des Français c'est
pour beaucoup une source d'inquiétude
quand on quand on sait que le médecin
approche de la retraite quand on doit
faire des kilomètres et attendre parfois
des semaines pour avoir un rendez-vous
chez un
spécialiste ce combat je sais que vous
le partagez et c'est aussi celui de mon
gouvernement avec le ministre Aurélien
Rousseau et agès firmain lebaudau nous
sommes
déterminés beaucoup de mesures ont d'ors
et déjà été prises pour régler le
problème à la racine nous augmentons le
nombre d'étudiants en médecine nous
renforçons la coopération entre les
professionnels de santé et permettons de
déléguer certains actes certains actes
je pense par exemple aux certificats de
décès qui pourront désormais être établi
par les
infirmiers d'ici fin 2024 10000
assistants médicaux auront été déployés
auprès des médecins libéraux partout sur
le territoire ils permettront aux
médecins de se concentrer pleinement sur
leurs patients et si le nombre de
maisons de santé a déjà doublé depuis
2017 passant de de 1000 à plus de 2200
nous en visons 4000 partout en France
d'ici la fin du quinquena c'est concret
chaque maison de santé c'est 600
patients de plus pris en charge chaque
année et vous le savez pour réussir
l'accès aux soins il faut aussi
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers là
encore nous avons agi notamment avec des
revalorisations de rémunération sans
précédent ou une meilleure
reconnaissance du travail de nuit et les
weekends mais au-delà des métiers nous
devons veiller collectivement à ce que
chaque territoire soit attractif je vous
propose donc de travailler ensemble dans
les prochaines semaines pour mettre au
point des pactes territoriaux afin
d'accompagner les professionnels de
santé logement accès aux crèches emploi
du conjoint sécurité transport c'est
ensemble que nous pourrons attirer les
soignants et leur donner envie de
s'installer dans nos
territoires autre enjeu don dont je vous
voulais parler avec vous la
sécurité là encore c'est une attente for
forte de nos concitoyens nous mobilisons
des moyens sans précédent après avoir
créé 10000 postes de policiers et de
gendarmes lors du précédent quinquena
avec Gérald daranin nous allons en créer
8500 de plus d'ici 2027 et le mois
dernier le président de la République a
annoncé le déploiement de 239 brigades
de gendarmerie à travers tout le
territoire dans l'Hexagone comme dans
les outres mers mais je sais également
tout le rôle joué par les polices
municipal au quotidien les polices
municipales sont déterminantes et elles
l'ont encore montré lors des violences
urbaines de cet été je veux leur rendre
hommage leur action a été
essentielle aussi comme je l'ai annoncé
à la Sorbonne le 26 octobre devant les
maires des communes touchées par les
émeutes je vous propose de
une nouvelle étape pour les maires qui
le souhaitent et beaucoup d'entre vous
nous ont déjà sollicité nous allons
permettre à certains de vos policiers
municipaux d'accomplir des actes de
police judiciaire sous le contrôle des
parquets il s'agit de leur donner les
moyens d'agir plus efficacement contre
la délinquence du quotidien la sécurité
est un défi collectif c'est ensemble que
nous allons le
relever
enfin je tenais à évoquer la question du
logement vous le savez mieux que
quiconque nous traversons aujourd'hui
une crise du logement et nos concitoyens
s'inquiètent de pouvoir accéder à un
logement
abordable là encore le gouvernement agit
et j'ai eu l'occasion d'annoncer de
nouvelles mesures la semaine dernière à
dkererque mais nous avons besoin
d'avancer tous dans le même sens pour
répondre à cette crise je mesure combien
vous êtes sollicité au quotidien par
celles et ceux qui cherchent un logement
je sais aussi que le logement est
l'exemple même de ces politiques
publiques où les compétences et les
interventions s'intriquent au point que
l'on ne sait plus à la fin qui est
responsable de quoi alors nous porterons
au printemps un projet de loi de
décentralisation des politiques de
l'habitat nous voulons vous donner de
nouveaux leviers par exemple pour
l'encadrement des meublés de tourisme la
maîtrise du foncier ou encore pour les
attributions de logements sociaux le
ministre Patrice vergrit commencera les
concertations sur ce sujet dès la
semaine
prochaine Mesdames et Messieurs les
maires les défis à venir sont immenses
j'en ai évoqué certains d'autres nous
attendent je pense notamment aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 dont
l'organisation mobilise déjà certains
d'entre vous et qui seront une grande
fête pour l'ensemble du pays en réalité
dans tous les domaines la France est
plus forte grâce à ses communes plus
forte grâce au travail à l'engagement au
dévouement de ces élus locaux c'est
ensemble et ensemble seulement que nous
pourrons écrire l'avenir ensemble que
nous apporterons aux françaises et aux
Français les réponses et la protection
qu'ils attendent ensemble que nous
pourrons assurer la cohésion nationale
alors que certains tentent de la
fissurer d'attiser les rancœurs et les
violence d'opposer les Français entre
eux alors devant vous j'ai voulu porter
un message clair à vos côtés le
gouvernement répondra toujours présent
nous serons là pour vous accompagner
vous aider pour permettre à vos
initiatives et à vos projets d'aboutir
pour répondre à vos difficultés et aux
préoccupations de nos concitoyens
ensemble porté par le seul intérêt
général par la volonté d'agir nous
avancerons et améliorerons le qutien des
Françaises et des Français vivent les
maires et les communes de France vive la
République vive la
[Applaudissements]
France La
Marseillaise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà sur cette marseillaise se conclut
donc ce 105e congrès de l'Association
des mairres de France sur ces deux
discours hein celui du président de
l'AMF David lisnar qui a donc été suivi
par l'intervention de la première
ministre ellisabeth bornne et nous
allons et bien tout de suite parler de
ces discours avec Géraldine Chavrier
bonjour bonjour vous êtes professeur des
universités vous êtes spécialiste du
droit des collectivités locales du droit
constitutionnel local merci d'être avec
nous et également sur ce plateau romain
Gaspard bonjour bonjour vous êtes
journaliste à La Gazette des communes
alors romain tout d'abord et bien que
retenir de cette déclaration d'amour on
peut le dire et c'est assez classique
hein lorsque la première ministre vient
ici à l'association des mares de France
une déclaration d'amour avec de très
nombreux points qu'elle a développé
qu'est-ce qu'il y avait d'important
selon vous dans ce discours la la
première annonce importante c'est des
annonces financières il y a eu deux
grosses annonces financières la première
c'est l'augmentation de la DGF oui la
dotation globale de fonctionnement la
dotation globale de fonctionnement 100
million d'euros ce qui fait une
augmentation à 320 millions d'euros
alors contrairement à ce que la première
ministre a dit c'est en dessous de
l'inflation en tout cas selon les les
études qui sont sorties parce qu'on
serait plutôt autour de 485 millions
pour atteindre l'inflation en tout cas
c'est les chiffres que disent que donne
la MF c'est pas très loin mais c'est pas
très mais c'est pas l'inflation
exactement et la deuxième mesure
importante c'est la le prolonge du filet
de Sécur euh du de l'amortisseur
d'électricité qui est une mesure euh
pour les communes qui ont vu qu'on signé
des contrats d'électricité avec des cûts
qu' avait qu' on flambé même si ça
redescend comme ils ont signé sur 2 sur
3 ans sur 4 ans des fois leur contrat
ben en fait ils vont continuer à subir
des prix très élevés et donc le fait que
l'amortisseur continue pour ces
communeslà c'est très important et
l'année dernière c'était quand même 1
milliard d'euros euh pour 2023 enfin le
PLF de l'année dernière donc celui de
cette année de 1 milliard d'euros
l'année prochaine on verra combien ça
fait mais mais c'est pas négligeable
comme comme mesure donc vous retenez
plutôt des des mesures d'urgence pour
des communes voilà pour l'année
prochaine d'un point de vue financier
oui parce que le reste c'était plutôt
Emmanuel Macron qui a annoncé les grands
axes plus politiques oui effectivement
parce que là on a senti que et bien
ellisabeth band venait aussi un peu
assurer le service après-vente après les
promesses d'Emmanuel Macron d'hier qu'il
a faite devant les maires qui étaient
rassemblés à l'Élysée pour plus de
décentralisation pour la refonte de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement de
plus en plus complexe a dit la première
ministre mais là on est encore sur sur
les paroles et pas encore sur les actes
Géraldine Chavrier oui d'autant plus que
c'est un discours qu'on a quand même
entendu à de nombreuses reprises le
président Emmanuel Macron s'est engagé
plusieurs fois au cours de ces deux
mandat à réformer la décentralisation et
pour l'instant on a quand même quelques
qu que concrétisation pour le statut des
élus par exemple la loi de 2019 a permis
d'avancer un peu pour et là ça pourrait
aller encore plus loin on nous annonce
un nouveau texte de loi statut
de sa formation et ceetera là je pense
que on est plus on est au-delà des
paroles parce que l'État lui-même a
intérêt cette fois-ci à agir compte tenu
du rythme de démission des maires mais
aussi des conseillers municipaux dont on
parle beaucoup moins euh il on va se
retrouver à un moment ou un autre dans
une situation où les candidatures vont
s'assécher et on va avoir des
complications institutionnelles parce
que peut-être qu'il voudra réorganiser
des élections en cours de mandat donc on
est absolument certain que concernant le
statut de l'élu et après les événements
comme vous le savez du maire de
Saint-Brévin ou de de de la rose on sait
qu'on va avancer sur ces questions sur
l'aspect financier je pense qu'en effet
fait la dotation globale de
fonctionnement ça sera pas juste une
annonce euh elle est très critiquée elle
est très compliquée une
indexation est envisagée là c'est c'est
ce que j'ai entendu dans le dans le
discours de la première ministre et
ensuite je pense qu'en effet on va avoir
une
concrétisation
concernant les relations avec la
préfecture ça je pense que c'est devenu
absolument le couple maire préfet hein
ilst plusieurs fois l'accent a été mis
là-dessus un couple qui a fait ses
preuves notamment pendant la pandémie et
donc il faudrait vraiment le péréniser
euh je crois que même on va aller
au-delà de la pérénisation je pense que
le préfet qui avait déjà reçu un pouvoir
de dérogation au normes dans le une
perspective de de souplesse et de
simplification va certainement se voir
attribuer davantage de de possibilités
de de dérogation donc oui le contexte he
c'est celui dont on parlait Géraldine
Chavrier effectivement c'est et bien la
crise d'é voocation des maires 40
démissions de Mair par mois et sans
parler effectivement du reste du conseil
municipal là-dessus il y a agir pour et
bien remobiliser redonner un petit peu
de de souffle aux élus locaux romain
Gaspar oui oui c'est une des priorités
on l'a vu c'était dans le thème il y
avait les agressions d'élus et ça il y a
déjà beaucoup d'acctes qui ont été pris
il y a la PPL au Sénat la proposition de
loi qui a été votée qui va arriver àass
l'unanimité le 10 octobre exctement et
puis plus il y a le il y avait un grand
plan annoncé par la ministre des
collectivités donc ce sujetl il est pas
fini parce que il reste le manque de
moyens de la justice à traiter mais
c'est très avancé par contre sur ce qui
va remobiliser rendre attractif ce qui
va faire que les élus représentent plus
la société parce que aujourd'hui on a
quand même 40 % de retraité on a peu de
jeunes que 2 % de moins de 40 ans donc
c'est c'est c'est assez peu
représentatif par rapport à la société
c'est un vrai enjeu et puis l'enjeu des
candidatures évidemment pour 2026 donc
ils vont devoir bouger ça va faire un
texte de loi premier semestre
2024 qu'est-ce qu'il y aura dedans c'est
toute la question parce que on parle de
beaucoup de choses des droits sociaux de
la retraite euh on
parle de d'avancer sur les indemnités on
parle de formation tout ça ça fait
beaucoup de sujets tout ne pourra pas
être traité donc il va falloir voir où
sont les priorités et c'est là où ça va
commencer aujourd'hui tout le monde est
content parce que on n'a pas encore
tranché quand on va arriver dans le dur
du texte que ça va pouvoir être déceptif
sans doute par rapport aux attentes et
puis il y a un enjeu derrière euh
financier où on sait que Bercy va être
très regardant et qu'il va pas falloir
que ça coûte trop cher non plus donc ça
ça va être le le le le second le second
stade euh l'aspect financier va va jouer
parce que l'un des problèmes de la loi
engagement et proximité sur les
indemnités c'est que c'était beaucoup à
la charge des communes et toutes ne
peuvent pas se le permettre il y en a
certaines qui peuvent se le permettre
mais pas toutes et donc là aussi la la
première ministre a annoncé une petite
augmentation de 15 millions d'euros de
la de la dotation pour les les
rémunérations pour les élus locaux oui
ça c'est dans la logique de d'une
refondte plusement pour les élus de
petites commune rural a-t-elle précisé
c'est ça c'est une dotation pour aider
aux rémunérations des toutes petites
communes parce qu'ils ont pas les moyens
de de les financer par leur budget
propre mais ça c'est qu'une première
étape et c'est pas grandchose 15 million
d'euros c'est c'est c'est vraiment pas
grand chose dans mais mais c'est une
première étape et on voit qu'il y a une
ambition affiché une volonté
affichée quand même hier Emmanuel Macron
en a parlé aussi donc on voit que ça
remonte juste au chef de l'État et donc
il va falloir aboutir là-dessus et il y
a et il y a une vraie possibilité d'une
d'une réforme transpartisane parce que
on le voit à l'Assemblée c'est dirigé
par violess pilbou qui est député
Renaissance mais aussi Sébastien Jumel
député communiste la mission qui
travaille dessus et qui va faire des
propositions et donc c'est peut-être un
sujet où on voit une voix de passage ce
qui est pas du tout le cas sur la
décentralisation où on voit que c'est
beaucoup plus clivé et beaucoup plus
compliqué à à à trouver une une solution
effectivement et là pour le coup c'est
la mission peut-être impossible d'éic
vert cette mission sur la
décentralisation on a entendu bien
encore une fois à la fois David lissnard
à la fois ellisabeth borne faire
référence à cette mission peut-être une
question préalable est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron a été comme lui est souvent
reproché un président recentralisateur
pour
vous oui mais il n'est pas le seul on a
un phénomène de recentralisation qui est
très fort depuis 2010 euh mais il est
évident que sous le mandat d'Emmanuel
Macron on s'est retrouvé face à un
président de la République qui a une
force de proposition qui est énorme et
cette force de proposition parfis elle
oublie complètement la collectivité
territoriale vous savez par exemple ce
qui peut-être extrêmement
symptomatique c'est l'augmentation du
point d'indice pour les fonctionnaires
territoriaux tout à fait logique il n'y
a pas de de raison pour que ces
fonctionnaires territor
ne puisse pas en profiter en revanche
l'annonce est faite l'été alors que le
budget des collectivités territoriales
est déjà complètement bouclé donc c'est
quelque chose qui est imposé ensuite il
y a aussi des des raisons pour cette
décentralisation c'est que sa sa force
vitale fait que la transition écologique
est quelque chose qui qui devient une
priorité pour lui parce qu'il est
attendu et notamment par les plus jeunes
sur cette question mais cela implique
des objectifs qui sont fixés par l'État
et qui ont un impact terrible sur les
marges de manœuvre des collectivités
territoriales qui se retrouvent à devoir
se lancer dans une rénovation
énergétique à très grand frais sans
qu'il a les financements derrière dans
un délai très limité qui du fait du zan
vont se retrouver effectivement avec un
pouvoir en matière d'urbanisme qui est
plus limité zéro artificialisation zéro
artificialisation nette effectivement on
est à la fois avec un individu qui
connaît assez mal les collec é et qui va
comme ça rentrer frontalement dans la
collectivité par exemple quand il nous
annonce il y aura tant de collèges qui
seront rénové en fait ce qu'il veut dire
c'est qu'il y aura des subventions mais
les collèges c'est pas l'état c'est
décentralisé donc il y a une
personnalité et puis il y a un climat
aussi qui fait que il il est dans un
phénomène de récentralisation mais on
peut croire du coup la promesse du
président de la République celle qu'il a
faite hier devant les devant les maires
devant les 1 rassemblé à l'Élysée alors
il y a beaucoup de choses à dire la
première c'est que malgré tout il est
pragmatique et que la décentralisation
peut aussi avoir des avantage pour
l'État euh le l'inconvénient c'est que
vous parliez de de la missionovert il
est il est sincère dans l'idée que il
veut passer un nouvel acte de la
décentralisation le problème c'est que
la conception d'Emmanuel Macron d'un
nouvel acte de la décentralisation c'est
celle d'une réforme de l'État c'est pas
du tout celle d'une décentralisation ça
son questionnement est encore celui des
différentes strates territoriales ce qui
est quand même la meilleure façon de
fâcher les élus locaux c'est quand même
pas une très bonne façon de commencer
une réforme de la décentralisation sa
question est encore celle de la
lisibilité pour le citoyen des doublons
et donc de la spécialisation des
collectivités non la question
aujourd'hui pour un vrai acte de la
décentralisation ce sont les règles de
fonctionnement de la décentralisation
c'est l'autonomie financière c'est la
libre administration c'est la la
différenciation c'est la possibilité
pour une collectivité de se voir
transférer un pouvoir réglementaire
d'application des lois là il a rien
besoin de faire Emmanuel Macron il a
juste besoin d'appliquer le droit
existant est-ce que dans les projet de
loi aujourd'hui qui concerne les
collectivités locales on a ce réflexe de
différenciation ou de renvoi au pouvoir
réglementaire des collectivités locales
non donc je pense qu'il est sincère dans
sa volonté mais qu'il part encore avec
une une vision très étatique de ce que
doit être la décentralisation donc
centralisateur malgré lui dit Géraldine
Chavrier Emmanuel Macron peut-on croire
qu' qu'il change réellement de logiciel
et et est-ce vraiment aujourd'hui
indispensable nécessaire romain Gaspard
je pense que le changement culturel il a
pas été fait parce que on voit que c'est
encore très vertical que il y a même si
on dit avec le fond vert par exemple il
y a plus d'appel à projet il reste quand
même beaucoup d'appels à projet il reste
une façon un préfet qui est qui devrait
être au centre et qui l'est pas toujours
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'agences il y
a une organisation de l'État qui est
assez lourde et dans les doublons on
parle beaucoup des doublons dans les
collectivités mais il y a aussi souvent
des doublons avec des agences avec des
des organismes de l'État qui font que il
y a il y a un un un nombre d'acteurs
énormes sur certaines politiques et ça
ça a pas changé après là où il y a eu
une prise de conscience c'est par
exemple par rapport à ses prédécesseurs
il y a pas eu de baisse de la
DGF en valeur làdessus il y a une
stabilité mais il y a aussi moins VO qu'
y a une augmentation pour la première
fois depuis 13 ans exactement mais il y
a plus de levier fiscal pour les
départements il y a moins de levier
fiscal pour les les communes parce que
c'est les propriétaire maintenant avec
la taxe foncière qui paye au lieu que ce
soit tout le monde avec la taxe
d'habitation la fin de la taxe
d'habitation la fin de la CVAE tout cela
a joué bien sûr sur l'autonomie fiscale
des collectivités donc un président
décentralisateur on peut pas dire ça par
contre une volonté de de renforcer la
déconcentration et d'être davantage
territorial et avec des politiques
territorialisées ça ce changement de
culturel il a été fait après dans le
dans à ce que l'État l'applique et à ce
que de chaque préfecture ça redescende à
ce que les préfets de département soient
renforcés tout ça n'est pas été fait et
dans les compétences la demande d'un
pouvoir réglementaire c'est ça que
demandent les les maires aujourd'hui on
en est très loin aujourd'hui bon bien il
y a aussi aussi eu un autre sujet très
important bien sûr qui a été abordé lors
de ce congrès on était même le thème les
menaces sur les communes sur la
République sur la sécurité des maires
là-dessus et bien écoutez ce qu'a dit
tout à l'heure la première ministre
ellisabeth
borne être maire être élu c'est être en
première ligne face à la brutalisation
de la société les menaces les injures
sur les réseaux sociaux les agressions
trop d'entre vous me disent qu'elles
sont devenu leur
quotidien vous le dites quand nos
communes sont attaquées nous ne
banaliserons rien nous ne pouvons pas
nous habituer nous refusons de nous
résigner si vous n'êtes pas en sécurité
la République n'est pas en
sécurité en mai dernier après l'attaque
inacceptable dont il avait fait l'objet
j'avais reçu le maire de Saint-Brévin et
et les représentants des associations
d'élus vous m'aviez fait part cher David
lissenard de plusieurs propositions à
votre écoute avec vous avec les
ministres Gérald armanin Éric Dupont
Moretti Christophe Béchu et Dominique
fort nous avons construit un plan
national de lutte contre les violences
faites aux élus son principe est simple
un meilleur accompagnement et une
fermeté implacable contre les
auteurs cette ferm ne se P pas de mots
ce sont des actes ceux qui s'en prennent
à vous encourront désormais les mêmes
peines que ceux qui agressent nos forces
de
l'ordre mais je sais que le compte n'y
est pas encore je sais qu'il y a encore
trop d'affaires qui n'aboutissent pas
nous devons faire plus et nous y
travaillerons avec vous et avec les
parlementaires engagés sur ce sujet et
sur ce plateau j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir David lissnard bonjour
bonjour président de l'Association des
maires de France maire de Cann tout
d'abord
votre réaction au au discours de de la
première ministre et par exemple sur ce
sujet dont on vient de parler